is blowbacks, y'all. How do you Is it blow blacks or blowbacks?
It's Bo Blacks. Bo Blacks. In his Only Fans bio, it said Blowbacks.
Yeah, when you're on one side. That's why we quit the channel
ultimately. It's just because like it just wasn't like sustainable
for growth. I was I remember like DMing Dior. I was just like,
"What the why is everyone supporting this? If Hassan said the
same thing, everyone would be up his ass." You know, Hassan said
like America deserved 9/11, which I think is actually a much
more defensible position than like the Destiny firefighter thing
dream. It was like the Destiny conversation,
there was Bax and then there was Kinetic Kell and it's like I
instigated all three of those conversations, dude. The Kinetic
Kell that was awesome,
dude.
Dude, no, before that, dude. Tommy C, he's a, you know, he's
a commentary OG. He comes from a different time, you know. He's
a What? Sometimes you got to take the dog. Old dog out back.
I have people saying that I need to give him a me and Nick need
to give him a fireside chat.
Might be able to get some other people in too. You want to hop
on? You ask questions if you want. I'm going to keep doing this
until you do hop on though. I think I'm in the Collins channel.
Yeah, I'm in the Collins channel from a state. Oh, dude. What's
up? How's it going? Yo, what's going on, man? So, I'm like semi-retired
from commentary obviously and so I don't keep up to date with
this stuff like as you know minuteby minute as I used to back
in my prime. Let's just put it that way. But I so as a result
I haven't seen Ethan Klein's newest video actually. But I've
been hearing some like crazy things about the lawsuit. So I'm
super confused. Right. So Denim's reaction to the content nuke
was 4 hours long and the content nuke was like an hour and a
half. So why is Ethan Yeah. Yeah. So she added like, you know,
at least over twice the amount of commentary, right? So why is
Ethan suing her again? So like um so he is suing her for both
that and for reacting to the stream before it, for watching the
stream before it. And the stream before it, she gets up from
her chair, walks away. She does not do meaningful commentary.
Right. Okay. So I heard she walked away for like a minute or
something like that. Like 2 minutes. Yeah. 2 minutes. Okay. So,
is that what we're crying about? Like,
I just don't I don't understand. Yeah. The thing that like upsets
people or upsets people who like Ethan is that she basically
said, "Okay, we're going to stream this when when it goes live.
We're going to stream it right away." And although it's not used
as Ethan's logic, I think the biggest reason to be upset is he
ran the video, his content nuke as a premiere. And she streamed
on Twitch over top of that premiere while people were directing.
You know, I think Hassan's community, the anti-3
were pointing towards her. Why would it being a premiere like
you know affect her ability to react to it? Like does she have
to wait until it ends?
Well c it goes to you know for the four pillars of fair use creating
a market replacement right so she's streaming over top of him
people who might be watching it invested enough to watch like
this is the argument. I don't necessarily believe this all the
way but it's the argument. I know I'm I'm sure you're not on
his side on this, right? But I'm just like trying to understand
like how he even thinks he has a basis for suing her, right?
Like, so if you premiere a video, suddenly nobody is allowed
to react to that until the premiere is over. Well, that's my
argument. He doesn't make that argument on his side. It's just
that he thinks that she did not react substantially enough. And
the argument he makes in the lawsuit is that her commentary is
poor. It is misleading. It is straight up lying in some places.
It is like uh like basically it's lost the commentary is poor.
Interesting. So I know the argu like obviously you know if she
was rereaming it maybe I'd feel a certain way about it right
cuz that's kind of just rereaming it on your show. I feel like
you have to like kind of be there and be present and give some
amount of commentary. But she did give commentary you know whether
or not it was like just you know ass or if she was lying or if
her commentary was stupid. I don't really care about that. But
she was there. she was present while watching the video and adding
her own thoughts to it. So, it's like I just can't I I can't
fathom how anybody could even be supporting this. But, I've been
tweeting a lot about Ethan tonight and boy have I I mean I haven't
been getting like a lot of but a lot of people are uh super upset
at what I have to say about it. I'll say that. So, I'm just wondering
like why people would even think he has a basis to even sue Denims.
And I'm focusing on Dems because I noticed her reaction was like
4 hours long. I don't know if maybe he has like a better argument
with like Casey Tron or uh who's the other person that he's suing?
Oh, Froen. Definitely way better arguments for them. So, I think
the argument in general is probably that it's just straight up
like I think if you're going to watch somebody's hour and 50
minute video even over 4 hours, there probably still an argument
that that's not fair use, right? that that could still be determined
like copyright infringement. So, I think that's probably what
he's banking on. But if here's the thing, and the analogy I've
used for this is like basically a whole bunch of people have
been street racing and Ethan Klein doesn't like how the street
races are going anymore and so he called the police. But like
everybody was engaging in this exact kind of content, right,
where they'd watch long videos, they'd react and as long as it
wasn't disrespectful, you weren't getting up and walking away,
that was considered like transformative. Most people wouldn't
with you, right? Well, yeah. I I think it's total if you just
like are just rebroadcasting somebody else's content and you're
not even present to even talk about it. You know what I mean?
Like I think that's I think that's Yeah. Like it's it's dog content
is like a content creator at bare minimum, right? Without even
getting law. Yeah. Yeah. But if he got mad, he's like, "Okay,
you're literally just like rebroadcasting my content while not
even being there to talk over it only for the sole purpose of
just, you know, people not watching my version of it. Yeah, you."
But if she's there giving commentary, I don't care how dog her
commentary is or how stupid she is. Like that doesn't really
matter to me. If she's there, that's she's transforming it. You
know, she might be transforming it into something worse. Like
you can get into like, oh well, were Denim's contributions really
like worth listening to? That's a totally separate argument,
but if she was there, then why the are we crying about this?
Like who cares? But you're saying that he had a better argument
for Froken and uh and um Casey Tron. Is that So I've heard from
people who looked into the Frogen one that the Froen one despite
her getting up, she does get up and walk away at some point.
Let her like chair react for a little bit. I've heard that her
reaction was fairly substantial as well. Um for Casey Trron,
I'm pretty sure Casey Tron just straight up watch partyed it.
Casey Trron doesn't really any of her content so or not a lot
of it. Well, yeah. She's too stoned for that. She's not even
like in the room. She's not even present for her own con. Even
if she's there, it might as well be a chair react because she's
so stoned that she's not even really present in the same room.
So maybe for that maybe for that case it's true. I don't know.
I believe that is something along the lines of the argument she
might make. So well I know like in the in the actual in the actual
like uh document, which again I haven't read, he does make reference
to her weed usage. Like he's like she's stoned, which is crazy
to me. I don't know. It's It's very funny to like laugh at like
the ridiculousness of this lawsuit, but actually supporting it
is like a completely different thing to me. I don't know. I I
can't support any of this. I feel like the problem is is that
it's going to set like a legal precedent. Well, okay. I have
two I have two problems with this. One, I feel like it's going
to set a legal precedent. And now us as content creators who
react to all day long in live streams are going to have to be
extra super hyper careful that even though we're giving fair
use commentary, we have to like spend extra amounts of time making
it super fair use so that if anyone wants to sue us who doesn't
like us, you know, they have no argument altogether. And then
here's the other thing, right? Wait, wait, wait. I just want
to respond to that really quickly cuz I think that is a concern.
But my bigger concern is that it's going to chill critical commentary
and like buff like
just yas queening commentary, right? Like if I'm positive to
somebody, then they're not going to sue me, right? But if I'm
if I'm actually critical and I think somebody's totally wrong
or they're harmful, then that is right to get sued, right? You're
absolutely chilling criticism, like critical. Well, you're totally
incentiv
totally super incentivized to only watch content that you agree
with. If you watch something that you don't like and you're going
to piss off the creator, then you have to worry about them suing
you if they get that as mad about it. Quimman's going to lose
everything if Ethan wins this. Okay, he's going to be the biggest
victim uh of the precedent that this sets. Like all of Quean's
videos will be up for up for suit. He's going to have to pay
hundreds of thousands in compensation to Tommy C is going to
sue Queen. Tommy C is going to sue Queen. Yeah, Queenman himself
will go for like seven minutes without saying anything. He's
not even in the room. It's going to Yeah. I mean, he'll sit on
camera quietly, dude. You don't He'll just dead air the courtroom.
Oh my god. Yeah. No. Well, here's the other thing I'm worried
about, too, with all this stuff, right? So, you guys know, of
course, I'm sure you know people have been talking about the
Matt Hos lawsuit, right? So Matt Hos sued H3H3 because he was
mad that H3 watched one of his videos and was super critical
and making fun of him, right? This just feels like H3 doing what
Matt Hos did to him but other people. Like H3 does not give a
about copyright here. He's obviously only suing people because
he's mad at who those people are because these people have been
after obvious but that doesn't really as far as I I did some
research on this that doesn't really matter for like the uh legitimacy
of the suit right just because you doesn't matter for the legitimacy
of the suit it matters for the legitimacy of him as a content
creator
saying like I'm
spiteful and addictive of course we already knew this we already
knew that he's saying like I'm suing these people and it's going
to help it's going to benefit the consecr creative community.
Even Mudahar, and again, we're not surprised by any of this,
right? So maybe I'm just preaching to the choir here, but even
Mudahar, like before this video even came out, was saying stuff
like, "Oh, I've seen this video beforehand." Like when H3 is
hyping up the content nuke, Mudahar was like, "Dude, I've seen
this video. You guys are going to love this. It's going to change
the content creator ecosystem." And that's what H3 and Mudhar
and all the people that are on H3 side are saying. They're like,
"It's going to change the ecosystem." And I'm like looking at
this, I'm like, "Yeah, it seems like for the total worst, right?"
I mean, we're literally just H3 has become Mad Hos and we're
supposed to like this now. I don't get it, man. So maybe I'm
just preaching to the choir. I don't know. I I don't know enough
about this case to argue it yet. I'm just kind of talking to
you guys to like learn more about it, but it seems crazy to me.
Yeah. I would just say really quickly that I think I think he
absolutely has like a legal case and could win all of them, even
the Denims one where it's like a substantial reaction. I could
easily win that. I think you can easily win that. Yep. Um but
the thing is, right, the thing is that he says to like kind of
ease people's concerns, oh well, I selected a really high bar
for the three I'm going after. I I the I these people explicitly
stated um that they like had intent to divert viewership from
his videos. Here's the problem with what he's suing them under.
He's suing them for statutory damages, not actual damages. And
under uh fair use and statutory damages, whether or not it's
intentional
uh has no basis on whether or not you can sue for those types
of damages. It just has a basis for the potential payout. Even
if somebody uh when you're suing them for statutory damages did
not knowingly do it or maliciously do it, you can still sue them
for up to 30,000. I think the the the malice part
I thought it was 30 grand. I think it's we I can just check.
Go ahead. what I read yesterday said 30 grand and then with the
inclusion of Malice it can go uh up to over 100 grand right so
just because he selected a high bar for 25 somewhere in there
yeah just because he selected a high bar for these three people
doesn't mean that by setting this precedent under uh under the
rules applied to statutory damages it doesn't mean this can now
be used for non-malicious actors as well see here it is up to
it is up to 30k per work for for anything and then 150k K for
willful infringement. Yeah. By the way, I don't want to call
it malicious because it's not malicious as in that that's where
I think Ethan is tricking people. It's not that malice on their
part allows him to sue for 150. It's willful understanding that
you could be violating copyright, right? Got it. Yeah. Intentionally
like him trying to say the malice thing where they say they're
taking views away from me that although that the you know proves
willful as well, it's like not actually the standard. The standard
is willful. So basically this his idea that like XQC would be
a part of some other standard is just weird to me other than
he just doesn't want to fight with XQC because XQC I don't know
if you guys realize this had not even remotely a substantial
react and is literally in a clip from his video where he's like
I'm not reacting to this guys I'm just watching. Well yeah exactly
that's what I was also going to ask you guys like why is he not
suing Hassan let alone other people like XQC? Is it just because
of optics? Because if he sued XQC people would be furious. Yep.
Yep. He's not suing Hassan for like probably different reasons,
but for XQC, it's almost certainly just optics right now. He
doesn't want to start multiple fronts, a fight on multiple fronts.
So, okay. So, going back to something you said earlier, right,
you mentioned that like he actually does have a strong legal
case even against denims. So, like what would that what would
that be specifically? Like if she fair use react to it, like
how would she get over? Uh cuz I think the concept of fair use
reacting has never ever been settled for like watching an entire
video. I think the concept of fair use acting like the precedent
that H3 set was you pre-screen the content you cut out clips
you want to criticize and you criticize those clips right that's
never gone to court before I thought H3 set the standard like
for everything with his own lawsuit against Matt or sorry with
Matt Hos's lawsuit against him but yeah I guess that's not the
case yeah that was I believe that is basically for clips and
there there is like some I forget what the actual elements are
but it is basically if you have clips that are like tightly tightly
clipped, you're just using anything. Basically, your commentary
should be decided and you're using the clips to like inform your
commentary. Whereas with like reaction content, there's not really
fair the concept of like fair use reaction content almost doesn't
actually exist where like you you should have to know you should
be making a criticism because you have no way to filter and know
that you'll even have something relevant to say until you've
watched the content. That's not always true and obviously everybody
participates in an an environment where we all accept that this
is okay right now, right? Okay. So, this is the first time anyone's
ever like sued for like their videos being reacted to like in
full on a live stream. Um,
I don't know if it's the only time. I think it's the I if the
other ones happened, it would maybe have gotten settled. Yeah.
Okay. Well, that's crazy to me cuz I didn't know that. Okay.
So, that's why I was calling another stream to like learn about
stuff that I didn't know. That's crazy, dude. And see, I don't
know how that helps us. I don't know how that helps us as streamers.
Like, they're hyping this up like as if this is going to be like
a great thing. Like basically I feel like what everyone thinks
is that these lawsuits are going to stop chair streamers like
people that just go live and just like play your [__]
and don't say a word. But then I'm looking at the people that
he's suing and at least with Denims admittedly Denims is the
only case that I've looked at and I watched her reaction like
not all of it. I skimmed through it but she was talking so she
didn't come across as like a chair reaction streamer to me. So
I'm like how the is this going to help us if Ethan wins? Like
that just means I have to be extra hyper careful. Like, you know,
I got to pause the video every like 2 milliseconds to make sure
I don't get sued if I watch a video for somebody that I don't
like. Like, what the Yeah. No, I like I I that's probably not
my major worry, but that could be one of the things where you're
like more concerned about that. Again, for me, it's to me like
the criticism thing is the big one I could keep coming back to,
but like yeah, we just don't know. Ultimately, we literally don't
know how this is going to go. And um I'm trying to see somebody
just sent me something. So I just got linked to I guess from
some copyrightlley.com
an article here that's explaining that like basically yeah this
could change the permissibility of like um reaction content in
general. I think I think I think there is real concern that reaction
content may be like in trouble in a general sense. Yeah. If uh
if this lawsuit goes through. So maybe we just, you know, maybe
Asmin Gold and Denims fund a, sorry, Asmin Gold and XQC fund
a settlement for denims so it never goes to court and never does
anything. You know what I'm saying? Yeah. Well, look, here's
the thing, right? I'm a commentary YouTuber. I've made plenty
of videos on reaction
channels and reaction streamers that don't really add anything
to the content. I've made millions of videos on XQC and stuff
like that, right? But I started thinking about my position on
those things and I'm like, does this even really matter? Like,
I don't even know if reaction streamers as a whole take away
viewers from like YouTube videos that have been originally produced.
I feel like like most people that watch a YouTube video or a
reaction streamer are watching it for the streamer rather than
the video itself. Because, you know, if you if you're just like
an XQC like [__] watcher and you're just like, "Oh,
I love XQC every day. I tune in to XQC every day." and he's just
watching some random [__] about like some science
some science video or whatever, right? You were never going to
watch that video in the first place, but because XQC your favorite
streamer is watching that like, you know, you end up watching
a video that you were never going to give a view on in the first
place. Yeah. And like I that's an okay argument that sort of
counter there's another argument. I don't know if you followed
this at all in 2023 where it's like they're still they're crowding
out the marketplace essentially. So, like if it was just mostly
original content, if this was like uh disabled in some way, like
if you weren't able to react to content like this, that like
YouTube would be mostly recommending like original content to
people, they wouldn't be falling into stream content because
they wouldn't be getting, you know, it wouldn't ever snowball
in the first place. There's like a couple I I don't like those
arguments. I personally think the same thing you do kind of that
like probably the streamers aren't taking that much away. But
I do think even if they're not taking that much away that they're
making like bank off of that and their lives are made way easier
by these people, they should be compensating those people. I
think most people agree that like some kind of revenue sharing
thing where you could make a an original piece of content and
just say like, "Hey, if you want to react to this thing in full,
you give me like 10% of your revenue or something for it." Like
if that existed, I think that solves a problem for everybody.
I agree with that. I've always thought like YouTube should have
a system where it's like if you're watching the majority of a
video on your own stream, YouTube should be able to automatically
detect like, hey, this streamer is watching somebody else's video.
So, the revenue from that VOD should be shared like 50/50 or
maybe it's like some percent that's like fair or whatever, right?
where it's like at least some of the percentage of that revenue
earned from that video should be sent to the original creator.
So that even if somebody like reacts to your video and they get
like a million views and your video only has like 10K, well,
you still get like a percentage from that video from the reaction
streamer that watches it. But that's a different argument. But
yeah,
I think almost everybody agrees on that. It's just like it's
really difficult to implement and it's not like nobody's getting
pushed to implement it, so it's just kind of whatever. Yeah.
Yeah. No, for sure. Um, yeah. I don't know. That's just all I
had to say on the Ethan lawsuit. I was just curious like what's
going on here. But it seems pretty and I definitely uh am not
feeling compelled to support it. I'll say that. But yeah, I just
I really don't like that. It's kind of just it's from like a
petty small place. Like he just doesn't like these people and
that's why he's suing them. That could be like fine, but that's
not what he does in his video. I don't know if you watched the
video yet. I think you said you didn't. But his video is um it
starts with him talking about 2023 react gate and how like chair
reacts are really bad. Oh, they're so bad and like all of this
stuff is is a big deal. And then he he finishes talking about
XQC in his debate with XQC and he goes, "But I'm not going to
like sue XQC cuz I don't want to like I think he says I don't
want to chill him or something. I don't want to like I don't
want to go after him right now cuz he wasn't malicious in doing
this." Why does he ever say why? He had like the he just he he
wants he his stated goal is he wants to go up to the people who
said I want to take views away from Ethan Klein by rereaming
this. Right. Which is his choice to do, but it doesn't make any
sense if you're going to also present yourself as the person
who's defending um like the space from these lazy chair reactors,
right? Yeah. Yeah. So, he presents himself as that and then he
goes after Denims for a legitimate reaction. He also he only
registered the the copyright for his stream I think a month or
two months after he registered the original stream. And so the
concern there is that after Denim's reaction. So I've talked
to a couple people about this. It seems to me like he might have
realized that on the content nuke alone if he sued Denims he'd
kind of look stupid. So he needed to to register this one as
well where she does chair react to the stream and she can say
oh or he can say look. And in his video, he never says this,
by the way. In his video, he puts up a Denim's like chair reaction
a couple times and basically implies that it's the content nuke
she's doing that to, but it's not. Yeah. Right. It's the stream
before that. Well, okay. I don't know if this is like a stupid
point, but I feel like he picked he very selectively picked the
creators that he's suing, and he picked like the most
creators of all time, right, to sue so that nobody would ever
want to even think about defending these people. He picks like
the most annoying in the world, right? And he he also only sues
women. And I've seen some people saying like, "Oh, it's ridiculous
people are calling Ethan Klein misogynist." I don't know. I feel
Listen, I'm a misogynist. I feel like Ethan Klein is low-key
one, too, dude. Like, I feel like he's only suing these annoying
ass women because he knows who get the least amount of [__]
pursuing these people instead of somebody else like Excy or Assad
or literally any male creator ever. that would be more challenging
in like the battlefield of public opinion to sue. I it just feels
like suspiciously easy to me like the targets that he's picked.
But I don't know. Yeah. That this is like where your principles
get tested, right? Are you actually like a principal person cuz
everybody I talk to about this when I like actually talk to them,
they eventually say, "Yeah, well, you know, you are right that
he's like lying about his motivations. You are right that this
seems like petty. But you know what? Despite that, I don't care
because it's froen. It's frozen Caseyron and Denims. Okay. And
those people. I'm just like, dude, that's Everybody falls back
to that. Well, it's exactly why you sue them. Yeah. Here's the
thing, right? If I I sympathize with that thinking. I sympathize
with that line of thinking, right? But here's what I've said
to those people. Okay. If you're like these people, well, guess
what? I'm these people, too, right? These people actually like
I'm not team Assan. You know what I mean? And I'm es and I'm
especially not team
or team denims or team Casey. Especially not team Caseyron. She's
the worst. Right. Okay. But she's actually I'm I listen. Casey
Tron trolling over this has been funny. Quite funny. Okay. What
has she done that's Wait, what is the funny thing that she's
done? She's just she's leaned into like the whole like high like
slob thing a couple times in just a funny way. Okay. Where she
basically is trolling or is that just her natural self? No, I
She is trolling cuz she goes like, "Oh, I don't even remember.
Did I really react to that? I don't even remember reacting to
that." I did see that. I did see that. I There's been a couple
funny moments. It's like, you know what? Look, here's the thing.
This is what I'll say is like if if people are like these people,
I agree with you guys. I'm like, "These people do." But here's
what you can do. There's a brilliant thing you can do. You can
just laugh at everyone involved. You can laugh at how psychotically
petty Ethan is for suing these people. and he can laugh to the
people that he's suing because them because it's funny that they're
going to be broke and poor and homeless or whatever, right? You
can just laugh at both. It's it's the best most satisfying freeing
feeling in the world to just hate everyone. Like, can't we just
adopt this mentality instead of picking one side or the other?
Um, yeah. But here's the thing. There is very very few people
I interact with who act like who act like it's morally justified
to hate Ethan Klein, right? I there's very few people, sorry,
maybe more that I interact with, but there's tons of people who
act like it's totally morally justified to hate the other people.
And that's like why they hate them is because they think it's
okay to do that.
Well, but hold on. But that but then it's only one-sided. They
don't they don't admit that like by that same rationale, you
should be able to hate Ethan Klein. They're like, "No, no, no.
Ethan Ethan got sent skulls. Actually, there's like a Nazi sword
that got used in a video about Ethan and uh
virtue signaling." Yeah, I know. It's the virtue signaling, you
know? It's like, and here's the thing. It is, I will admit, it
is more fun to hate one side over the other instead of hating
them all because when you hate one side over the other, you can
justify it for like 20,000 different reasons. Like, oh, he got
CPS called uh on him. Oh, he got skulls sent to his house. Or
on the other side, it's like, well, oh, Hassan, you know, has
platformed a terrorist and, oh, Hassan has said all these crazy
things or whatever, right? But it's like me, man. I don't know
if it's just me or whatever. I don't know if I've just been too
like logged off of the internet, but I just don't emotionally
care about either side to the point where I'm like super gunning
for one or the other. To me, it just depends day by day who's
funnier. You know what I mean? For a while, I thought Ethan's
side was funnier. I thought the content nuke was good. I liked
the content nuke. I liked a lot of things Ethan was saying against
Hassan. I don't like Assan. Now, I'm starting to think I'm starting
to think the other side. I'm starting to think actually Ethan
sounds pretty gay right now. And now I'm I'm team Hassan, you
know? Can't we just like switch back and forth based on which
is which side is funnier depending on the day? Like come on now.
Like why are we taking this so seriously? If that's what people
want to do and they're consistent about that, I'm fine with that.
I just hate people who are like, "No, no, no." Like, like these
people are totally in the right, the other side's totally in
the wrong. Anybody who feels that way is just like totally incorrect
about this whole thing. It's like Israel. It's funny. It's poetic.
Okay. It's ironic that it's like Israel Palestine. You think
either side is just totally morally in the right, you're probably
a Yeah. No, 100%. Someone said in the chat is flip-flopping is
what we do. Flip-flopping is actually based. And that's kind
of what I'm here to say to to this day. Not flip-flopping like
changing your mind on core issues, but like going from one day
saying like, "Oh, this side is base." And then the next day they
do something cringe and just changing your mind, just being like
these people. Like that's what we do here, right? Like it it
should be what we do. As soon as they lose us, we turn and then
hope that they become better. Come on. Right. Sure. That's how
I That's how I do it. People do things worthy of criticism. I'm
I'm going to not Listen, I I'm not quite in uh like chaotic mode
like you. Okay. So, I'd say probably if people do things worthy
of criticism, you should be able to criticize it. And if you
feel compelled to defend it, I mean, I don't know what to tell
you, right? Like chaotic, dude. I am I I'm not Kadak. I'm from
the cabal. Listen, I get my talking orders, okay? I'm very normally
not chaotic, you know? I get my I get the orders from the dawn
and I obey. But tonight I just don't feel like obeying, dude.
I just feel like saying it how I feel it, you know? Ethan Klein,
man. Uh he uh he's kind of annoying. Yeah, I I found him like
Yeah, I listen. I was on his side at first, too, but he he's
just gone too far. It's gone too far. It's too much. I mean,
did you even like So, have you been like anti I saw like a clip
of Destiny where he was talking about you and Quean and he was
like, "Oh, it's funny to see Jtock and Queman like twist themselves
in a knot trying to defend Idubbbz just because I'm pro Ethan
or something." Did you see that? I'm sure you did. Uh, yeah.
Yeah, he just totally lied. I literally criticized Idubbbz like
a thousand times over his [__] his stupid video.
Um, I think the only thing I basically the only thing I said
that was like pro Idubbbz in any way whatsoever was
I think uh he kind of showed that like the timeline showed that
Ethan was maybe lying about how the texts happened. I think there
was like some small critique there, but otherwise it was just
like this is embarrassing. This is gross. This is weird. Yeah,
I kind of recall having a similar criticism on my show about
the time. I can't remember specifically cuz I don't really remember
this internet drama that much, but I think I remember it on the
timeline and his content deputy. Uh I can't remember though.
But yeah, I think I think I saw what you're saying. Yeah. I don't
know. I mean, when content cop came out or like content nuke
from Ethan came out, were you just like watching those videos
just like at every point or was it just like you were just watching
them and just being like I didn't even watch a point here or
there. You didn't watch that content nuke. Well, no. I was like
uh I was like hanging out with Dan Saltman. Dan help me used
to come on my stream a whole bunch and I was like in Destiny's
community. Those were just my talking points. That was just like
the harvested from like my stream over like three to four months.
Like this was the anti-han zone. And but listen, those pro those
points are good points, right? When he defends the uh the Houthies,
kidnapping those unrelated civilians off of that ship. That's
awful. That's like the worst things he he's done on his stream.
As soon as as soon as Ethan went beyond those points, I think
it got pretty ridiculous. But no, I didn't have any criticism
for the content nuke stuff. I was very like when Ethan was saying
like Hassan's like anti-semitic and stuff like that cuz I don't
think Hassan is I always I always push back on that one. That
was one where Yeah. I just couldn't couldn't give that up to
people that Hassan was anti-semitic.
Yeah. Yeah. I don't think he is either. But I I mostly think
that like just because I don't really think like when Hassan
goes live every day he's like, "All right, another morning, another
bright and sunny morning. Let's see how it can stop those or
something." You know, I don't think Assan thinks like that, you
know. I don't know. Well, and the thing is is the reason you
shouldn't accuse him of anti-semitism if you don't think that's
how he's thinking is because then you don't even understand how
to like talk to him. Like if you just think he hates, you don't
understand anything about him. There's no way you could like
come to any understanding with him whatsoever. Well, you can
just instantly dismiss anything that he says because, oh, he's
just saying this because he hates them. you know, it just like
like saying somebody's anti-Semitic just like it removes any
reason for you for you to critically like engage with what they're
saying. So, it's kind of stupid. It's not good. Speaking of anti-semites,
have you ever met Straer before? No, I've never. No. Hello. Hello.
How's it going? What's up? Are you a big anti-semite?
Uh, huge. Actually, huge. Obviously, why I'm criticizing Ethan
Klein? I just want to read a quote uh to you boys. Um, just hear
me out. I want to make one thing clear at the top is that I want
to focus on the YouTube uploads because the Twitch streaming
itself is too much of a gray zone and there's industry standard.
I would be more hesitant to call what happens on Twitch a violation
of any kind. I just want to focus on what you XQC upload to your
YouTube channel. Is that okay? This was in a debate called a
video called This Debate Didn't Go as Planned XQC versus Ethan
on copyright in 2023.
That's crazy. That's crazy. So, and keep in mind at the time
at the time of this conversation, huge friends, right? Huge friends.
Huge friends. And XQC had already gotten that non-exclusive streaming
deal with Kick, which uh the New York Times described as one
of the largest in entertainment history because he got $70 million
and then was able to make 30 million more depending on uh performance
bonuses and certain metrics that he hit. And that conversation
is filled with Ethan making the distinction between where he
feels people are no longer making a good faith attempt to actually
react. And the entire time it's really focused on the YouTube
uploads and how he's screwing over smaller creators because he
had an example of somebody who had XQC had reacted to the video.
He like his editor used the same the same guy's thumbnail just
put his face on it. The same title just so we're aware. He did
that with the content nuke as well. just use the content nukes
thumbnail with XQC's face pasted on. Yep. Yep. Sorry. Continue
though. Same title, same thumbnail or And then XQC is like, "Well,
I should be able to do whatever I want until these people call
me out. They can just call me out." And Ethan was like, "Dude,
you're a huge creator. They you have to understand that what
people are like smaller creators are going to be scared to tell
you don't react to my stuff or like hey can you not title it
the same thing because they don't want to draw the eye of you
or your community because they will get relentlessly because
it's going to come off like they're being a wet blanket and trying
to ruin everyone's fun while they're like trying to react to
content. Yep. Oh yes. These were I I think I've pointed out a
couple of these arguments. Um specifically like the title thumbnail
ones. I didn't know that he actually identified because he was
best friends with the Twitch is like a gray zone. He didn't want
to criticize his friend, right? Which is just a good good window
into like how he thinks broadly about the internet and probably
why now he's not suing XQC. Right now he's neutral with XQC,
so he's not going to sue him. Hates all these other people. He's
suing them. This is very uh Well, yeah, because the thing that
the motivation for this obviously is not about infringement.
about criticism because he tried to even if you fall even if
you're transformative with your criticism of Ethan, if he feels
that it goes too far, he's going to try to hit you with a defamation
lawsuit like he'd wanted to do with Noah Samson. I don't know
what the status on that is. I don't know if it's been abandoned,
but he was threatening that. Um,
and then so like even transformative and comprehensive criticisms
of him, he will still find a way to potentially hit you with
the lawsuit because the point is to just make it so people are
on edge about criticizing him and they have to look over their
shoulder and think, "Huh, if I don't criticize him in very very
comprehensive ways or even if I do, sometimes if I go too far,
this dude could this multi-millionaire streamer and content creator
and content creator could hit me with like a really expensive
lawsuit I'm not equipped to handle. So, I'm just not going to
cover it." Yeah, I mean that's 100% spot on. I mean it's just
like, you know, he doesn't really want to go after people for
infringing on his content. He just wants to bankrupt streamers
that he doesn't that he doesn't like. That's pretty much it.
I mean, and the thing is what sucks is that like this I'm not
I'm not talking about legal consequences. I'm just talking social
consequences. See, if they don't react, he would have called
them out for dodging criticism because I'm pretty sure he criticizes
them in the content nuke. Um, and then if they react in clips,
he'll be like, "They only wanted to watch in clips. They don't
want to see the full context cuz they get BTFO. So, they try
to take it out of context to dunk on it and then they react in
full and uh they're still getting slapped with these lawsuits.
So, it just seems like there's not really a way to uh criticize
him that's not going to draw um draw his eye. Yeah. No, he's
veryful.
Yeah, he is. He's wrathful. And the out of context thing is a
big thing that like I understand this is what I think goes to
forming like he created this environment where you're supposed
to react to people. you need to react with the context. Uh, also
these people are because they'll never actually react to me with
context. And then they react to his whole video, his whole comprehensive
nuke, and he's like, "Yeah, I'm suing you." No, not like that.
I I plan to sue you. I actually plan to sue you before I release
this. In fact, I I'm going to make a video that explains that
my primary motivation for making this content was actually to
bait you into reacting it so I could sue you. Cool. Okay. Yeah.
I mean, well, does anyone believe that what he said in that video,
though, where he's like, "Oh, this is all bait and you fell into
my trap." Like, because I I heard that he said that. Well, he
says it's not that I wanted them to infringe on my copyright.
I just knew that they would. That's what he says. I feel like
that's like a crazy thing to like believe that he actually like
Oh, of course. to like take him at his word for that, especially
when he's carving out an an exception for XQC and Asmin Gold
for some reason, even though he's literally publicly feuded with
XQC over this very topic and has multiple hours of him just like
chastising him the entire time for all of XQC's flagrant violations
of free use or like fair use. Yeah. I mean, I saw people like
in my community or whatever saying like, "Damn, Ethan got him."
And I'm like, "You are nuts if you believe that that really is
how it happened." I mean, that's just me saying that, but it's
like, how the I don't know, but yeah, I don't know why he's not
doing Excuse. I mean, we know why, but you know, rhetorically
speaking, like Ecuy is like the poster boy for the type of thing
Ethan was talking about in his video. But again, it's not about
that. It's just about bankrupting creators that, you know, uh,
he doesn't like and creators that he feels like he can get away
with bankrupting really unlikable creators that and he does some
sneaky things. He does some sneaky things in that video. Like
when he shows Hassan's channel and he was trying to say like
one of the worst offenders that this is Hassan. He's actually
showing a fan channel. It's not Hassan's actual channel. Hassan's
actual channel
um has much shorter segments. They're highly edited and the emphasis
is on Hassan's commentary, not on the content that he's reacting
to. It's the fan channels that are re-uploading that. But if
you just watch that video and you'd never actually seen Hassan's
content, like I hadn't cuz when like um I don't like I don't
really watch Hassan like ever. You would get the impression that
Hassan just like rips full bods and and throws them up there
with no editing, but he doesn't. Well, yeah. Like I've seen Hassan's
main channel before. Like aren't his videos usually like 40 minutes
or something. It's they're very
Yeah, they're very trimmed down where it's just him talking,
you know? It's not even like if he's watch Yeah. 14 minutes,
20 minutes, 22 minutes, 30. Yeah. So these videos are not obviously
like full VODs of him just watching a singular video. Like other
channels reupload that, but as Ethan Clen admits, oh that's a
gray area. We can't really go into like Twitch reactions on Twitch
because that's a gray area. So it's all and even from there when
he's showing Hassan and like the chair reactions, he zooms out
and you see all of the screens where all the streams where he
did this and it's like 10 to like it's like a huge like array
of all of these different streams. And when I was reacting, I
looked and I was like, "This is mostly news. It's not small creators
that he's reacting to." Like there was like a Tik Tok, but the
majority of what he if he got up um and there was like a chair
react happening. I was like, "He's like watching PBS, dude."
Like or like [__] C-SPAN or CNN. Nobody's going to
give good luck getting anybody to like give a [__]
that oh okay, Hassan wasn't like transformatively reacting to
the news. Is CNN copyright striking him? No. Then like who gives
a Yeah. I mean, I will say I have covered him before like I cuz
I've done like a lot of videos on like react content. I remember
him watching like a JX video where he was chair reacting to that.
He like got up while playing like a full JX video. Now that was
back in like 2022. I don't know if he still does that to this
day. Oh yeah. I mean, Jaxi was the one that actually has the
far more substantial and and like good criticisms because they
show examples of like how to do reaction content and how to not
run a foul of like not pure use in the technical sense of the
law, but like obviously showing creators who make a good faith
effort to react and be transformative versus the ones that are
just sitting in the corner laughing and nodding and basically
straight straight up just like reuploading other people's content
and how it like harms small creators and how like here's what
you could do. You could shout them out. You could link their
You could um like not skip through the ads, like that kind of
stuff. Like actual guidelines that are productive to help people
without just like reaching for a lawsuit or whatever. Yeah. No,
I mean it's ridiculous that like people are saying like, "Oh,
well, if you're against the Ethan Klein lawsuits, that means
you're like pro-chair reactions." No, I think those reactions
are right. But it's like the idea that anyone was watching content
nuke from Ethan Klein and just letting it play with like no commentary.
I mean, that's delusional. Like the Hassan fans and like Hassan
orbiters that were watching this video, of course, they were
pausing the video and just like, you know, spamming their talking
points or whatever throughout the whole thing, right? Like nobody
was actually just letting that video play like uninterrupted
because the whole video is like anti-Asan. If like you're a pro
Hassan streamer watching that, of course you be like stopping
it and like, you know, defending Hassan and stuff like that.
Well, at the time that that content nuke dropped, I'm trying
to think back. I was like, what was my timeline like that week?
And it was just clip after clip after clip of Denim's reactions
and people dunking on her for her the way that she went about
um
yeah her counter arguments. It wasn't people being like dude
she straight up didn't not even try to refute anything that she
said. She's just sitting there like not saying anything like
I was like wouldn't we would have noticed this you guys. I mean
I can't say the same about Frogan and Casey Trron because they
just don't have the same viewership. Um,
but it just seems like it would have been more readily apparent
that this that was their intention with that. Um, but now it's
only a thing that people are are claiming after the fact because
it's coming up now in this lawsuit, right? Yeah. Yeah. And he's
already said he said on Instagram he was like Hassan actually
went about is like the perfect example of of fair use because
Hassan reacted to it with Idubbbz for like a charity fundraiser
or stream for like eight or nine hours and he only reacted to
like half of it. But the thing is is that if you're saying that
that's a good example of how to do it, there was a financial
uh or like even if Hassan didn't personally profit off of it
because the money and like revenue generated from that stream
went to a charity, it still is demonstrative
even if he didn't personally reap the benefits of it to react
to that content. He could only do that because of the the existence
of the content nuke, right? So that's Ethan conceding like, okay,
it's possible to have high viewership watching my content nuke.
It's possible to make generate lots of revenue while watching
my content nuke, but I'll still say it's fair use even with if
those other two factors are at play. But he doesn't want to apply
that in Denim's case because he points to the fact that she had
higher than normal viewership
um and was like asking people to subscribe. I mean, of course
she would, right? She has higher of course she's going to have
higher than usual viewership. I mean, the content nuke was like,
you know, the peak day to stream if you're like a Hassan hater
or an orbiter. And Hassan didn't stream, right? Hassan was gone.
And Hassan's Discord and Hassan's community pushed everybody
to Denim's stream. Yeah. So, it's just like crying over the fact
that like, oh no, she had a higher view. Of course, she'd have
a higher viewership. Like, what what the You know what I mean?
Like is that because she was just ripping his content or is that
just because she had like you know I I don't want to say like
she had a banger stream that day cuz again I'm sure that it was
right obviously but you know for her for you to be a top tier
Hassan Orbiter covering the content noob from age three Hassan's
number one op number one enemy of that time you know that is
going to be a premier show for you and obviously there's going
to be a high viewership for that. And yeah, if you have a high
viewership, you're going to tell people, "Hey, sub, like the
video, subscribe to the stream, give me money, right?" Because
you have the most amount of people tuned in. So for H3 to sue
based on that, it's just stupid. I mean, he just
Well, the the other thing he's mad about, which, you know, doesn't
fall under copyright like significantly. I'm being told they
can a little bit, is the fact that she says, "Yeah, come here.
Watch the stream." Or she says, "Guys, thanks for watching the
stream. Thanks for taking a like or a view away from Ethan Klein
by watching the stream. She said, "If you enjoyed not having
to give him a view and like my content, you should subscribe."
Well, see, this is the thing. This is why I can't support this
lawsuit, cuz I watch people's videos all the time of people that
I hate and I sit there and I say like, "Yeah, this guy. We're
going to watch it on my stream." I've said that joke a million
times on my show. I'm not even kidding right now. So, I can't
even support this lawsuit for that reason because it's like I
say the same. It's a funny thing to say, you know? I mean, is
it should you should you say that? You know, that's a different
discussion, right? But I I say when I'm watching a video from
somebody and I'm on it, I'm just like, "Yeah, this guy, you know,
you watch it on my stream where we're just dunking on it." You
know, she said
content, a thing that's trivially obvious when people are hate
watching a piece of content through a creator they know aligns
with them. is like, yeah, I I will have watched the content pretty
much in its entirety without directly supporting them because
I watched it through this person who was just like on them the
whole time and that's why I'm here. But it's different content
though. Like, you know, it's you're watching somebody react to
something and just destroying it rather than if I want to like
know what the arguments are in Ethan Klein's Continent, I watch
Continent. If I want to see somebody ripping it apart, I'm going
to watch Hassan or some Orbiter cover it or something, you know,
like it it is transformative still. And if you want to watch
someone queening it, you watch XQC watch it. Well, her saying
it like I don't even think XQC said yes queen. I think XQC basically
didn't talk. He had like really I like I I just I saw a clip
of him of Ethan reacting to him being like guys I'm not reacting.
I'm just watching
and Ethan was like king. Yeah. And that's stupid to me cuz that's
worse like XC watching it as like a semi friend of Ethan. Like
that's worse to me. It's like oh so he's just actually replacing
it right. Whereas if I'm watching it for somebody that hates
Ethan Klein, even if they're not saying much, you know, it is
still watching it from a different perspective. You have the
chat, you have everyone who's like, "Ah, this guy his stupid
talking points." You you are watching it in a different lens
than you would be from somebody that's like semi pro ethan or
even just fully pro ethan, but I don't know if that's like an
argument that holds up in court at all, but to me at least, it's
different to be watching it from somebody that hates the content
rather than somebody that is supportive of it. Well, yeah. It's
like, did people subscribe to Denims at the end of her reaction
because they believed they were going to be able to watch H3H3
content like repeatedly
without Yeah. without supporting support or No, I know, but it
like almost implies that like if she's a market replacement,
if you're subscribing to her that you're like, "Oh, Denim Denims
is the place that I can watch H3 content without it um without
having to support them." and that if she stops doing that that
they're going to withdraw the subscription or they're going to
not donate to her. But I don't know if that's actually the case
cuz she reacts to a bunch of different stuff. Isn't it more likely
that if people are subscribing at the end of her reaction, it's
because they liked what her reaction was, not what she was re
not because they think, oh, she's probably going to continually
like copyright infringe and she's not an she's not like an Ethan
hatewatch channel. She is like her own channel that does mostly
politics content and happen to get into some Ethan content there.
Yeah, cuz she was already like I mean this like overstates it
or whatever because she saw as a very modest platform size compared
to like other political Twitch streamers, but she was like the
number one female political Twitch streamer before the feud with
Ethan, right? And after the feud with Ethan, that still is the
case. So, it's clear that she's able she was able to make a career
out of this before she even got into this beef with him. Well,
yeah. Like anyone that clicked on her stream that wasn't already
like a fan or follow of hers was watching it because they're
like, "Hey, I like Hassan. I want to hear a pro- Hassan person
review this video so that any like thing that's said about Hassan
that's like incorrect or can be rebutted against, I can hear
that argument from somebody that wa that is watching the video
alongside me. You know, they're watching it for a completely
different reason. That doesn't take away from El E Klein's view
because if they're going to watch the content at all and they're
watching for Ethan Klein's channel, they'd be watching it for
a different reason, which is to just hate watch it, right? Yeah.
And the other thing is that he tries to say that or he he insinuates
based on one post that exists on the r/H3 snark subreddit that
directed the like Reddit users of that sub. Go check out these
creators so you don't have to support Ethan uh Ethan Klein directly.
You can watch it through and then it named some creators and
Denims was on there. I think I don't know if Rogan and Caseyron
were on there but like at least two of them were on there. Did
you use Snark mods, too? Or sorry, uh, H3 snark mods. Yes. And
they're named in the lawsuit. But what's funny is that in Ethan's
case against uh where he's defending himself um against Ryan
Kavanaaugh, who's suing him for defamation, the clients argue
that they have they cannot be held responsible for anything posted
in the H3H3 subreddit because they're not actually mods of it
and they're not affiliated with the mods. So they can't be held
liable for that even though it's literally of their community
but they're not technically like attached to it. But he can draw
a connection between
Froggen Denims and all these other creators to snark directly
because of a public post that could have existed without there
being any coordination. And the sorry you're forgetting the other
core piece of evidence straight raid which was at the end of
her stream straight raid had a a tab open that was on H3 Stark
proving she coordinated with them apparently.
wait. What is that? I I think she's just looking at something.
She's watched clips from there, right? Like it's but it's not
coordination. Like the allegation is that they coordinated to
move people away from his content. Okay. Straight away just blew
my mind because I forgot about the Ryan Kavanaaugh lawsuit. Like
H3 was literally sued because he watched like a didn't he watch
like a Jake Paul boxing fight? like he pirated that [__]
and openly promoted the fact that he was pirating it because
he specifically said he didn't want to give those people money
because H3 is like some sort of or sorry Jake Paul was some sort
of like alleged and he didn't want to give that guy money. I
might be totally butchering this cuz I I kind of forget the details
of this whole situation but dude I forgot about that [__]
That's crazy that H3 was sued for this exact [__]
a a definitively provable case where he was stealing content
from somebody like paywalled content
uh from an organization
and now he's going to virtue signal about how important copyright
is when creators just watch his videos and don't like him. Uh
yeah, he's obviously lacking in most principles. He's obviously
just like a piece of He's just a bully, right? He's just like
a internet bully. I can't believe I forgot about that cuz I covered
this, right? But again, I don't really have like a strong like
memory for YouTube drama and [__] like that, right?
Like some of this like escapes me. But it's like, dude, that
happened and I cover that [__] And that's crazy that
we're now in a situation where like Ethan Klein is supposed to
be like the messiah who's like standing up for like you know,
creator rights and uh you know, consecrators who have their stolen
from them or something like that, right? Like I know like obviously
in that case he was stealing from like a corporation or like
a boxing organization, not like an independent creator, but still
like who the cares, right? It's still the same principle. Oh
yeah. And if they sued him, they could definitely they would
win and like the legal defense of like but your honor, they have
lots of money. It would definitely not hold up if like they're
not going to care about that. They're going to be like, well,
they still have rights, dude. So holy [__] that's
crazy, man.
What an enlightening conversation this has been. Yeah, Ethan
Klein.
The other thing, and maybe this is like uh tell me if this is
too much of a reach or a gotcha, but I swear in the content n
cuz I've never watched the whole thing. I've only seen clips.
He argues that Hassan ended up signal boosting uh bada
and that yei teenager by platforming them, right? And in bada's
case, it's just because Hassan reacted to the videos, right?
um whether it's transformative or not. I actually wouldn't I
wouldn't be surprised if Hassan's reactions to the Banipanata
videos were not particularly transformative because I don't know
what extra commentary Hassan would even add. But like it's possible
that you can uh like Ethan's acknowledging that it's possible
regardless of whether or not you're adhering to fair use standards
that you can still end up signal boosting a creator just by having
them on your platform and on your screen. even if you're not
being transformative or whatever, it's possible to to make them
bigger just because you're exposing them. Okay. Well, here's
this is like an even more like insane reach from my end, right?
I covered Ethan Klein. I've been covering Ethan Klein negatively
since 2019. In 2020, Ethan Klein promoted a doxer and alleged
like child sharer, Brick Bong Returns, who's like this insane
black bald streamer who used to be in the commenter community
back in like 2016 and he was of course exposed and you know Keemstar
worked with a lot of people to get him like perma banned from
the internet and stuff like that because he is like a guy that
like will send you like child to like try to up your and stuff
like that, right? Jesus. But he he made a video when Keemstar
worked together to uh get this guy banned off the internet. Obviously,
Brit Bong made some gay video where he was like, "Kemar is trying
to go after me. He's trying to accuse me of sending all this
like terrible [__] or whatever." Right? Ethan Klene
played that video in I don't know if it was the original continu
he made on Keemstar or if it was one of the follow-up videos
like content nuclear winter, some of these things like that,
right? But H3H3
specifically promoted this guy both on his main channel and on
his podcast. This is a guy that like, you know, I think Bad Empanada
is terrible. For the record, I think I mean, he doxes people.
I'm pretty sure he docks people. I I don't know, but I'm I'm
pretty sure I've heard him doxing people. Bad empanada seems
like a bad guy to me, right? Britbong Returns is much much much
much worse. and H3 promoted this guy without spending any amount
of effort looking into who this guy is. Or maybe he did know
who this guy was and he just didn't care. I don't know. We questioned
H3 on this multiple times. He never gave us an answer. This is
2020 drama. So this is all like ancient [__] right?
But like I remember this happening. So it's kind of rich for
H3 to like morally grandson nowadays and be like, "Oh, you're
promoting a doctor.
You're promoting somebody who hurts Personally,
he used to run like bot chains that would d like every time I
would go live. I I would go live like every day for like years.
And every day I'd go live, my address, my home address, all of
my friends home addresses, all of my YouTuber friends, their
home addresses would just be turbo spammed in our chats. Like
there'd be like 80,000 bots just spamming that all at once and
we'd have to like ban them all one by one. This would happen
for years because of a guy that both H3H3 and even Comedy Shorts
Gamer, KSI's brother, promoted at the same exact time because
both of them were asked at Keemstar and Keemstar is the guy that
was is responsible for getting this guy banned off the internet.
So, not to go like full like, you know, I'm trying to like bore
you guys with like stupid drama lore or something like that,
right? But when it comes to this point specifically, it's kind
of rich for him to cry about people being irresponsible with
who they platform just by watching somebody when H3 did the exact
same thing with somebody much much worse. No, I mean I think
that's boring. I mean, it's pointing out just like a blatant
hypocrisy. Very interesting. Yeah. Sounds like um sounds like
to me, okay, when Gokanaru was most needed, he may have disappeared.
Okay. Where is this guy? Where's the video? He's been liking
my tweets all night tonight. He's very much still around. Where
is Gokanaru? Where is Gokanaru's video? Okay, this this guy,
he did the uh what is it? He did the shot on Ethan what? 5 years
ago, right? Oh, wait. His video got taken down for harassment.
I forgot about that. His like original Ethan Klein nuke, right?
Now, wait a minute. We're not saying Ethan Klein was responsible
for that, are we?
I I might have been fans. I don't know. I read a thing cuz Bad
Banana and this uh YouTuber Ryan Beard got into some beef. Bad
Banana leaks their entire Discord exchange like like Instagram
DMs or correspondence or something. And in that cuz I went over
it on my stream. He links uh like a Medium article from a guy
who claims that he used to work for Ethan Klein and he mentioned
like through a firm, some sort of like PR firm or whatever and
how Ethan had like a history of doing this, but I had no way
to verify it. Um, but I'm going to try to see if I can't find
it. But he does mention in that in this Medium article,
uh, that he wasn't like Gokano was one of the people that he
was instructed to like try to get rid of the content or something
like that. Let me see. Let me see if I can't find it. And trying
to see is his his video is still up, isn't it? I don't even see
it here. Like the Ethan Klein going to scroll through and find
it. I don't even know when his original video was. He um apparently
he shot an effigy of Ethan in the head and that's probably what
got it taken. That's not funny by the way. Totally. Oh yeah,
that's what that's what that's what that person mentions that
that um harassment like bylaw on YouTube's terms of service was
was added because of Ethan's uh report or something like that.
Where is this? Well, that would be interesting. This whole like
I'm doing violence to you in a video game thing. Like you can't
do it on YouTube. Oh. Oh man. Yeah. Uh I'm I don't know. I've
been I've been offline for like 2 days and I'm very shocked that
there's still a lot of people like totally like hardcore, how
would you put it? Like in the tank for Ethan. I thought it would
have changed like within the past couple days after people started
evaluating the easy narrative. It's just the easy narrative.
Like nobody actually critically thinks like whenever I hear like
a situation
like that's going on on the internet, I'm thinking like oh what
do I think about this? Right? When mo when most people hear about
like drama or like something that's going on, they're just like,
"What is everyone saying about this? Let me just copy like the
most like realistically easy position for me to have or like
let me just follow what my crowd is saying." You know, it's very
difficult. It's It's very difficult for people to like think
about like how they should actually think about something or
approach a drama. And it's stupid to me. It's like I can excuse
it for like just average viewers because like if you're a viewer
like your opinion doesn't really matter that much. Sorry to say
that but like I mean that's just it doesn't really matter if
you're like a hypocrite as like a viewer cuz like you're not
a content creator. When you're a content creator you have to
think about like the opinions that you've given against other
people and you have to like question if what you're saying goes
against something you said like a week ago or a month ago or
a year ago. And if it does go against that, you have to explain
why you've changed your mind. But most people don't bother even
doing that or thinking about it at all. Okay, I found it. I found
it. I knew this existed. Okay, this is by Joe Reebons and it
was published November 23rd, 2018 to Media. It's called Change
of H3H3.
Full disclosure, I was once contacted contracted by Ethan and
Ela's company through my employer, as you will find out in this
article, which is not very long. And so I have some skin in the
game. Some names and other non-critical info might have been
changed to protect anonymity, but all of the key details remain
intact. Um, it really sucks to see people that you idolize make
bad decisions. Like many other people, I once trusted H3H3 Productions
as a voice of reason in online entertainment. To quote Ethan
itself, "In 2016, we could do no wrong. I've worked in reputation
management, internet marketing for almost a decade. So, I was
elated when I got the tip from my boss that we might be working
with a major YouTube channel only to find out it was Ethan and
Ela Klein. We started out talking to H3H3 through an intermediary
over email in late 2017, early 2018, who wanted to set up Ethan
and Ela and any of their staff with our guys in a call. The first
meeting between H3 and H3 and our team in January through February
2018 concerned promo and branding. But as time went on and their
podcast continued to get bad press, they pressed for our reputation
management services and other stuff the company doesn't advertise
on the front page. They asked if we'd be able to control the
amount of dislikes and likes they got on Reddit, YouTube, and
other platforms. And if we could somehow remove comments or even
file DMCA takedowns to remove any content that was critical of
their brand, which really rubbed me the wrong way. It was a great
contract, so we pressed on and continued to work as well as we
could to their specifications. My day-to-day work mostly consisted
of managing extensive networks of sock puppet accounts for the
H3H3 Reddit, Twitter, and YouTube channel, which is something
that almost every large content producer does to the surprise
of no one. Only very recently did Ethan Klein approached my manager
directly about new problems he felt his brand was facing. Ethan
Klein talked to my manager, Gary, about his concerns pretty candidly,
and I was present in the call to take notes while Gary and Ethan
worked out details. Ethan told us about a certain video by a
guy on YouTube named Gokanaro that he felt was very critical
of his channel and his character. And he links the YouTube video
and the YouTube video doesn't exist and posed a serious risk
to his brand and he asked us what we could do about getting the
video taken down if we could submit a DMCA request and what other
avenues he could pursue. We told him pretty plainly that the
video was likely protected by fair use laws and Ethan immediately
flew off the handle and threatened to end the contract. We ended
up meeting there and told him we'd pick it up with him another
day. The following week, Ethan got back into a call with Gary,
myself, and co-orker Trent, and explained in an exasperated tone
that he had the perfect plan, and all he needed to do was act
on it. After shouting at me and my boss, Ethan railroaded anything
we said and encouraged us to implement a plan to make it look
like all of his critics were attacking him from a purely anti-semitic
angle, that the attack on his brand and character was an alt-right
conspiracy from 4chan. When we objected to the racial angle,
he insulted Gary personally and told us we were hacks and losers
before apologizing, throwing a charge back our way, and ending
the contract. I was pretty devastated, not because the job reflected
poorly on me as a marketer, but because I was a direct witness
to the catastrophic fall from grace of one of my idols. I used
to listen to their old videos or go to sleep or have a laugh
on a bad day. But I will never be able to look at H3H3 the same
way again, knowing that Ethan Klein would take advantage of racial
divisions in the United States to accuse his critics of anti-semitism
by having us create sock puppet accounts, oversee a plan to reinforce
his narrative, and shut down any legitimate critics with such
an underhanded set of methods. I hope you change your brand and
your attitude. Please. you were supposed to be the voice of reason
on YouTube, but now you make me sick to my stomach. Again, this
was published in 2018 if it's real. So, there's no reason to
think or like there's less reason to think that this is something
that was created opportunistically because if something like
this popped up in like the last year or two, I would be like,
well, okay, that's like convenient because it really maps on
to the [__] that he's doing now. But the fact that
it was published in 2018 related to Gokanaru, whose video eventually
did get taken down is kind of crazy.
Yeah. I don't know. Like I don't know how legitimate um the Gokanara
thing is or if they actually got him taken down, but I do think
it's funny that um they were coming with like the anti-semitic
defense in 2018. That would be well when he like the video is
linked and I click it and nothing shows up. Well, I assume it
was taken down. Well, yeah, it was removed. And then bada says
in these DMs to Ryan Beard, I don't know how he knows this, but
he says YouTube changed their rules because of him. They added
quote simulated violence against another creator. Um, and then
removed it for breaking the new rule. Lol. But I'd never see
I've never seen the Goku Naro video. I mean, to be fair, YouTube
does add rules all the time to justify getting rid of videos.
So, that's not really like a specific thing to Ethan Klein, but
it is interesting nonetheless to note. So, I don't know. I wouldn't
know. So, unlucky. When are you getting back on YouTube? Probably
not all that long. I I still don't understand.
We'll see. I don't understand why you're like even taken off.
Like what even h Sorry, this might be off topic. I don't know.
But Oh, it's fine. Um I had a video go up that went up multiple
times as like a monetized video that had like some bad language
in it. Like KYF slur was said in this video uncensored accidentally.
And well, I've got a few videos to delete then. Damn. Yeah. Ha.
So, I think they were not live streams, they were like monetized
videos. I think that makes a difference. And unfortunately, I
didn't have like anything on the channel. I'm I fully believe
that if I had this channel set up so that um I had like Google
or not Google, YouTube premium on it or something, if I was paying
the money, I fully believe it'd be unbanned. Like they wouldn't
have hit it. They would have like listened. But it was like a
fairly new account that I'd made to stream on YouTube and it
got hit. But um yeah. Yeah, I think um you should just ban evade.
Like YouTube doesn't really enforce ban evasion that much. Well,
yeah. Uh we'll see. I mean, didn't Sneak get banned and then
start a new channel and then that second channel got to like
a million before he get caught? I don't know about him getting
a million. I know. Well, here's the thing. YouTube does enforce
ban evasion a lot if you're like a highprofile like constantly
in the news type of figure. But if you're somebody that like
like if you're somebody like at our level for instance and like
if I were to get banned from YouTube the thing Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
If I were to get banned from YouTube I have a channel with 60K
but if they were to pull that [__] and I had to make
a new one they would not be like immediately hopping on that
to like pull me off again. So it's like you can kind of get away
with banan evasion if you're not like somebody that's like in
the news every day which I don't think you are. So I've noticed
several days have gone by and no just silk news. It would uh
true. Although yeah I was I was actually gone. People thought
I was dead for a little bit. People thought um one of the psych
I don't hang around these quarters. I don't hang around these
quarters that much. I don't know if Jay talks in the news a lot.
If you're like saying anti-semitic things and Fox News is covering
it. I don't know. No. No. just uh it's just the the most press
I get is just Destiny completely making up things that were said
on my stream for some reason. I I don't know. I feel like I get
like a weekly mention still of just like something that's entirely
made up. It's very strange. Am I stepping on dangerous ground
here? By the way, I know you the Tommy C Shlogic Civil War has
been going on. Like I I I literally have not even watched the
content like surrounding that. Am I like stepping on dangerous
grounds being here? Like I don't mean like should I be What do
you mean by dangerous? Yeah. Like what do you mean by dangerous?
Okay. Okay. Have you said nasty unforgivable things about Tommy
C? Uh probably pretty nasty things about Tommy C. I tried to
say neutral on Nicholas. I don't think that's worked. I think
Nicholas is Wait, you and Nick don't like each other anymore?
No, I like Nick just fine. I think he uh does not like me. He's
not a fan. I I'm like I think the last message I sent to him
was like, "Hey, man. I'm like totally cool if you ever want to
talk offline or whatever. I remember this now. This is this had
to do with our little argument about the this is about Willie
Mack. That was probably the most like uh annoying I got was I
just felt uh I watched that argument and he he said he would
talk to me for that and then he said he wouldn't talk to me after
a while and I didn't understand. But probably the most vitriolic
I got was watching your thing and reacting and just being like
this is so annoying.
Wow. But I I didn't like need to debate him or something. I like
I would be fine if he wanted to hop on here and like give his
side of some of these things, but yeah. So, it's not like a big
deal. And I'm not I'm not going after Nick. Most of the time
I'm like, "What do you think about Willie Mack? Is he like unforgivable?
Is he like banish territory?" No. I think the last thing I said
to him was something similar. It's like I I don't need uh I'm
like not trying to fight with people. But I think like that debate
we had on Queen's channel was like apparently unforgivable. I
just like I see it totally differently. Like I think you just
stream and I'd only watch like half of Willy's video when I came
on to talk about it. And that wasn't to say like I wasn't informed
in what I was saying. Like I knew what I was saying, but I I
wasn't like doing some super long thoughtout criticism trying
to Willy Mac. I was just like, "Oh, I think this is probably
what what should happen here." You know, I'll say this like I've
been noticing so I can't I was gone from the internet for like
a year or something. I don't even remember it. I came back like
last year for tox and then I was off for a little bit. I kind
of float around this community like I am active for several weeks
and then I like tune back out. But one thing that I've noticed
ever since I came back since like Boax was that there is like
this ongoing sort of war that's brewing between like I don't
know what to describe you guys as is like spicy chat. I don't
know if that's like a the correct like community to like describe
you guys as, but there's like a spicy chat versus commentary
community like war that it seems like the audience really wants
to have happen, but the creators involved don't really want it
to happen. Like you and Queen and Chud don't really seem to want
to like fight commentary people and commentary people don't really
seem to want to fight you guys, but the audiences really like
want to like have that happen or something, right? And I noticed
like it's like a very different it seems to be like a cultural
clash where it's like you guys sort of come from like the Destiny
community where Destiny's always been very like you know aggressive
towards like people that he streams with regularly whereas in
commentary there's like a different attitude. It's like you know
we're all friends and you know we sure we fight and argue and
stuff like that but it's not really we don't go as as hard on
each other as you guys go in on your friends. So, it seems like
there's like the difference of like, you know, uh I guess temperature.
I don't know how to describe it, but there's this war that's
been just everyone wants it to happen, but it's not happening.
And it's just like this kind of cold war situation. Is this accurate?
Am I correct in this like thing that I've noticed? Um I mean,
kind of. I think I think Quimman's got like a lot of criticisms
for people and I think he's got a lot of valid criticisms for
people, but I don't think he sees it as like something existential.
Does he hate me? I'm sure. Yeah, I'm sure if you got talking
to him about politics, he would not be Well, I'm not a I I Well,
okay. That's not It's dising to say that I'm not political. I
am like on the right because I'm like a conservative like Christian.
Like I was born and raised conservative Christian, but like I
don't really care. I I try to keep my show and my content very
apolitical. Like I I
content creator from what I can tell. like he was he was big
a big supporter of your I think he pointed your tweets out to
me tonight like on my stream he was on here earlier he's like
Augy's tweets I try to be very a-political I try to focus on
the funny I hate politics honestly I really hate politics just
because like I hate serious discussions online I like talk about
politics with my friends in real life but like on the internet
it's I'm very against that not against other people doing that
but me personally like I do not like getting political because
it just it's cancer I I like I like comedy more. I I wish one
of the things I wish the commentary community focused on more
was comedy. I wish people were more like interested in like being
comedians and being funny, but it seems like that's not really
the uh the case. So, I don't I don't know. But, uh I I like being
on the right because they're funnier than you guys. I got to
be honest. I The right can be funny. Uh some of it's not. The
right is getting better at comedy and the left is getting scared.
Yes. On our No, no, no. Okay, let me be clear. I'm not talking
about cat turd right-wing com. I'm not talking about like that
or something like that. I actually hate the right on Twitter.
Elon Musk is making me anti-right, but I'm I'm just saying I'm
like I don't know. I like right-winger like uh return to tradition
type. I like like griper like Nick Fuentes like style funny.
You know what I mean? We don't know anything about Nick here.
Okay. We don't know. We don't know anything. We don't we don't
like Nick here. Okay. Night. Massive. But in between Quan screaming
about Nick, he always says, "I love Nick."
So sure about that. This is a great video. It's so good. Sorry,
I'm playing a video in the presentation straight raid. That's
my bad with your icon here. And
oh, disavow. This You shouldn't be that happy saying unless you're
Pisco. Okay. Unless you're Pisco. No, you're ignoring the context
of that question, though. Wasn't that when Dean Withers was like,
"Would you rather support your wife or that is Oh, he is a fan.
He actually knows the exact context." Yes. I watched that. I
was like, I was thinking about that clip earlier today. I was
like, that is the stupidest question he could have asked. Like,
would you rather support your wife become president or you're
asking this like Nick Fuentes? Like, what the do you think he's
going to answer? Like, h Dean just loves being outraged. He He
just It's like his number one favorite thing. God. Good. Um,
just going back to like the commentary Civil War thing real quick.
I think that like Yeah, the audiences go against each other.
I think a lot of the creators don't dislike people. I think um
I think uh Willie Mack and Nick are not We got the perfect guy
in here discussion to come through Civil War. What's up, dude?
I'm just sitting here. I'm trying to figure out the lay of the
land because I'm launching a new show. It's going to be called
the third position with Auggie RFC and I'm just trying to figure
out like where everybody like stands with each other cuz I noticed
like a lot of people are like again it's all the audience the
audience has really become one thing I've noticed with 2025 commentary
is the chatters have all the control like the chatters like own
this [__] it's weird it's like uh they kind of control
what the narratives are going to be and like who who's going
to be at who it's all instigated by the chat. Have you guys noticed
this? No. I think chats have no agency. I think they're like
literally like [__] Maybe some people just let the
chat. I'm not sure. They're You got some commentary chatters
who do who are like wellknown, but I've tried talking to these
people. I'm No, wait. I know what I'm I know where I'm getting
this wrong. It's the Clippers. Okay. And you guys are very good
at setting up Clippers, especially Queen. And like I every day
I go on Twitter, I just get like a million Queen clips and I'm
like, "What the are these coming from?" And it's all these clippers
that the narrative like Chloic said this, you know, Tommy C said
this or whatever, Nick Dioro said this. And they kind of the
narratives of like, oh boy, like this creator said this opinion
about this guy. This is what we're all supposed to think. I don't
know, dude. It's It's very interesting. Why did you delete your
tweet earlier saying n I thought it was bad optics. I don't know.
I I uh I was worried that I was going to end up on Ethan Klein's
You think you got to defend the NH tweet on podcast live? Listen,
okay, I wanted my criticism to stand on its own and not be uh
dislabeled as anti-Semitic. I wanted it, you know. Wait, what
is NH?
What is that? I don't think I can say that on the stream. I would
if I could, though. Uh we're actually on kick. You could totally
Oh, wait, wait, wait. It just never mind. I know. I just never
mind. Can I say the on kick? Uh soft a yes. I can actually say
that. You can actually say this off day. Yeah. Oh, it stands
for pile. There you go. Thank you. Yeah, there you go. It's a
good song. Did you guys review it? It's not bad. Yeah, we reviewed
we listened to that multiple times. I can't believe you can actually
say the soft day on kick. That's awesome. I got to start streaming
a kick. Yeah. Yeah, it's good stuff. It's good stuff. Yeah. Interesting.
So, uh Yeah. I was just trying to figure out like the lay of
the land with like the uh commentary community versus I don't
know what you guys call each other, but I feel like there's a
lot of like chat instigation there. And and it's it's weird too
cuz like I'm giving all my text on Ethan Klein tonight and everybody's
like, "Oh, fattier." Very interesting. The uh the the bot wave
that comes whenever you criticize Ethan Klein right now. I've
said is it are they bots? I don't know. I don't know if that
I'm just saying bots as in they don't have any original thought
their own mindless drones sne
might be robots as well to be fair but well it's weird because
I've been making anti Ethan Klein content for like 5 years now
six years now and it's like I thought we all you know obviously
so you've been an anti-semite for six years that's a separate
no I've been criticizing Ethan Klein for six years that's not
also anti-semite but it's unrelated has not let it affect his
criticisms of Ethan Klein yes I anti-Semitics separately. I save
that stuff for later. But um yeah, I don't know, dude. It's just
been very weird that like like he's using dead people to attack
everyone that he doesn't like and it's not Well, I mean, it's
just they've already accepted like the whole um like drop kiwi
farms logic basically of well this community is harassing him
and they they called the authorities on him. So he has to take
him down and that's just just fine. Sure you can make the same
argument for like Keles's like oh I'm sure Kiwi forms I'm sure
one guy in Kiforms is something up to Keles. You don't think
that happens? Well yeah I mean yeah but the thing is it's the
same with with Ke it's exact same as Keles because when Keles
was crying about Kiwi Farms there was no proof that Kiwi Farms
had had swatted her. There was there was no proof of that. Obviously
you can't tell which anonymous user saw something online and
decided to take action on it. There's no way of proving that.
Uh so you couldn't prove it was Kiwi Farm. So, you can't just
go and blame the entire website for something that might not
even be someone from there. But in this case, we've totally abandoned
that and we've said, "Well, no, obviously it was snark. Obviously,
it was snark." Uh, so Ethan can do literally whatever he wants.
Yeah. And I had some people saying like, "Oh, no. He's just attacking
like the hypocrisy of like how Reddit allows one community but
doesn't allow the others." But I'm like, I feel like Ethan Klein's
war has been pretty obvious that he wants snar communities banned.
I feel like I've heard him say that before, you know, that he
want like that the whole point of his crusade against Snark is
that he wants these communities and like these styles of communities
like just removed from the platform altogether. Has he not said
that? Um yeah, he said well he's I don't know if he's ever said
I want all these hate communities gone, but he said isn't it
like disgusting that you can have a community like this and all
that sort of so no he holds them responsible. I have a screenshot
of an Instagram story where after the CPS call happened, he's
like, "I'm getting permits to protest outside of Reddit HQ and
then I saw another and then like when the Taylor Lauren's Ethan
DMs leaked or when she was talking to the producer, she was she
was the one that helped get him in contact with Reddit and she
was saying like there's channel like to to get the Snark thing
taken down." And that's when that's what led to that clip of
him being like saying that Reddit said, "Well, your community
is engaged in harassment, too. So if we took action only on like
one side of it, it would be like unequal enforcement. I mean,
it's just obvious they do like any any degree of well, I won't
say any degree because you can't prove obviously, you know, who's
called authorities or what, but by the posting, they do the exact
same type of harassment as any other hater community. H3 is perfectly
happy. Well, he he can't be held liable for that, nor can he.
That's what he said during the Ryan Kavanaaugh lawsuit. Not not
officially their their
he doesn't control what people post on the subre. He can't control
that. That's not to do with him. How can he control the entire
subre that's calling you? That's not to do with him. It didn't
matter then. Yeah. Well, see, this is why I was talking about
earlier like I hate like I mean I probably said political [__]
on the internet like a million times, but like I really try to
keep my content like apolitical just because like I hate political
communities on the internet because the problem I have with political
communities is they sort of encourage like the insane behavior
because the stakes are so high. Yeah, everyone's all in cuz they
feel like it it actually matters so they're like willing to go
to the absolute like Yeah,
they justify anything because it actually feels like super important.
Whereas in like when I'm talking about stupid commentary drama
of like oh this person called this person a you know what you
know it nobody cares cuz it's like just stupid petty. But on
the internet it's still petty but they don't view it that way.
So that you know the stakes are raised to a much higher degree
where like all this like unethical behavior is justified even
if you're against that same behavior. You know you can you're
allowed to be a hypocrite. I hate it. Well, he assumes at this
point everybody who criticizes him hates him for unfair reasons
because there was a content creator called Vanilla May. She's
like a big Tik Tocker now. She does Twitch streaming. And she
mentioned that Teddy Fresh had reached out to give her like free
merch to wear or whatever. And she on Teddy Fresh for like a
minute straight. And Ethan rips the video, puts it on his Instagram,
and he says, "Here's another I need to deal with. Why can't y'all
take a day off? so brave to dogpile a creator who has had the
CPS and skull sent to his house in retaliation for thinking Israeli
civilians shouldn't be slaughtered two days after a terrorist
executed two Israeli embassy workers. He literally posted this.
It's not satire. It's not a mockery of him. He posted this making
fun of my dog ABDL diaper lover merch where up to two Israeli
shot to death. Really while anti-semitism exists is really up.
It's so up. It's crazy. And it's like again it's like if somebody
on Kiwi Farms literally was like swatting Keles I would still
be against Keful's campaign against Kiwi Farms because that's
just one guy. You know Kiwi Farms is not like a monolith. Kiwi
Farms is not one guy doing like one action against somebody.
You know if a community it's a free speech community where people
do whatever the they want. There's really no terms of service
on that site. And so what if like one or two people in there
are crazy. You know what I mean? I'm sure there's crazy people
in my audience. I'm sure there's crazy people in anybody's audience
that are willing to like do some harassy
harassing crazy against other people. And I guess now you're
held responsible for that if you're my would never do that. Denims,
what does she do? She like watches videos where Ethan Klein is
talking about how um all of his kids and his wife and his dogs
all have the same disease and you can only get it through eating
the someone that's already got it. And then people and then Denim's
just like, "Oh, that's disgusting. That's like really disgusting.
That's gross." And now it's her fault that CPS got called for
some reason. I quoted Ethan from that clip and there was a comment
underneath my VOD being like, "You're you're spread." Oh, so
we're just spreading lies that that's how we get giardia.
Not that was not a joke. They did not realize. No, I was literally
just repeating what Ethan said. I wasn't saying that. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I'm just like thinking about this like how if I was covering
this, would I have made the same mistakes quote unquote? Right.
And it's like I would have, you know, when I cover people's videos
and I hate the video, I always say like, "Oh yeah, I'm glad you
guys are watching this on my stream instead of giving this piece
of [__] some view." You know, the same thing.
It's just hing. Yeah. So, I just think about it as like, would
I say the things that Ethan Klein is like criticizing to to such
a strong degree? Yes. You know, if if I was watch if I hated
Ethan Klein, I was watching a video of him talking about his
dogs like and his kids eating from the dogs like would I watch
that and be disgusted and talk about would I sensationalize it
to a degree that's funny? Yes, of course I would. Well, what's
weird is that he goes harder on denims for that than Bad Panata
for making the video in the first place that she's in Argentina
and there's no laws in Argentina. So, but he said at the beginning
of the video he doesn't give a about how much money he has to
spend and you can technically sue people internationally for
this kind of stuff. No, there's no there's no laws in Argentina.
I don't think I don't think you're aware of this. He's uh hired
mercenaries in Argentina to deal with bad empanada. Okay, we're
not going to get much more bad empanada content. Okay, that's
his recourse there. Money is no rip and furious George. So, what
do you all think of bad empanada? Is he like do y'all think of
him as badly as Ethan Klein thinks of him or like what's the
full story? cuz I don't know that much about bad crazy crazy
you know doctor political radical guy but I mean he's had some
funny moments and some of the he is
a you say you like Nick Fuentes cuz he's funny
is like leftist Nick Fentes in the sense that I know a bunch
of leftists and liberal and even like liberals and progressives
watch him but he's so embarrassing to affiliate with publicly
or to say that that they they pretend not to or they just they
say that they don't but I know secretly they are in the same
way that like I know a bunch of like MAGA people conservative
people, they have to be ambiently consuming Nick Fuentes cuz
he has to be coming up on their timeline, but they'll never say
that they watch him. Feel like that's Ben, but just for the left.
Interesting. Okay. Cuz like I don't know that much about him
and I don't know, you know, I I tried to look him up on Kiwi
Farms. They didn't really have that much information on him.
So like I was trying to figure out like what has he done? Like
what is he what is the crazy [__] that he's done?
I'm sure he's done crazy. I just couldn't find much information
on him. I think it comes down to doxing and then supporting his
community doxing people. Yeah. Like those those seem to be the
worst allegations. And I think most of the people who treat him
like he's the biggest baddest boogeyman on the internet um will
defend people who do those exact same things on their side or
will associate with them. So I just don't tend to take it that
seriously. He talks like somebody I actually like as a creator.
So or I've heard this at least. So I'm like not a huge fan but
he's also funny. So, well, I mean, psychopaths.
Psychopaths tend to be very funny, even if they're like totally
like morally reprehensible. A clip of him playing that terrorist
game, but you play as Okay. I had a debate with Connor about
this on my own show cuz I I talked about this multiple times.
Like, I know Ethan Klein talks about like bad like, you know,
played the video game where he's Ethan Klein. There is a very
similar moment where like Nick Fuentes was playing GTA 5 and
he joined the game. We watched that on stream a couple times.
Yeah. Yeah. Ben Shapiro is like, I'll never debate Nick Fuentes
because he me in GTA 5. I always thought that was the most in
the world from Ben Shapiro, but you know, is it similar to what
Bad Aanata did or is it like different there? Yeah, 100%. It's
the same. Yeah, cuz I was debating with Connor. I was debating
with Connor about this cuz Connor was like, "No, it's reasonable
for Ethan to hate that." And I'm like, "Is it though? That sounds
like weak." I don't know. No, it's reasonable for you to hate
that like somebody joked about like your wife. Like you could
be mad about I don't even No, I don't think you see that to cry
about this. It's like actually just okay to complain about it.
It's just like Well, it's like a video game. It's like Ethan
himself said, what was it? If there's another Holocaust, Ben
Pier should be the first one. Hey, he was suspended for that.
The gas chambers. Yeah, first one in the gas chambers. Yeah,
he said that and we're supposed to take it seriously when he's
like, "Oh, Bernardo went around in a terrorist game and said
he was hunting for secretaries."
Hey, Ethan Klein barred from video sharing platform for a week
after saying that if there's another genocide of he hopes the
conservative pundit quote gets gassed first or last
I mean he said like crazy but again I I've said crazy but I still
have like standards or whatever right like I'm very anti-doxing
and stuff like that so it's like well you like you know start
crying about doxing if you were doxing you know and that's the
thing right is like you're making statements about you know political
statements about how you think someone should be for their beliefs
or statements that they've made or propaganda they've pushed
to whatever and bad done the same thing and so you can't really
cry about that when you're engaging in the same Yeah. Also, did
I hallucinate this or did weren't there leaked messages where
Keeles admitted later that she was like intentionally trying
to antagonize Kiwi Farms? Like she was traveling and taking selfies
of herself in different like hotel rooms and places uploading
it to see if Kiwi Farms could find her. Did I just make this
up? I swear I saw these. I feel like I'm pretty I I very
I remember that. Yeah. Yeah, I know. I mean, she was obviously
like just saying like the pretty much like I remember like like
a week after she uploaded that video like I'm being hunted by
Kiwi Farms, she was posting where she was in Ireland. So, I don't
know. I remember that poutine in Ireland or whatever. It's like
there's like three places that serve poutine. Yeah. But yeah,
I don't know. Yeah. I'm not trying to like defend bad amput or
like whitewash like anything that he's done that's terrible,
but I'm just trying to like figure out I remember that one argument
about like the video game stuff and I'm like is that really what
we're focusing on? Like if he's doxed people and like done terrible
like that should be like the thing that's focused on but like
him playing a video game where he pretends to Ethan Klein his
wife like who the who actually cares about that? Well, he does
because when Hassan talked to him on Noah Samson's charity fundraiser,
he was like, "What happened there?" And I'm not just lied about
it because he said, "I only talked about he said he made a joke
about Ethan Klein being on Empic or something." And then he said,
"I never said uh Ela Klein's name." And it that's true, but it's
slippery cuz he said, "I'm looking for secretaries while he's
like playing." And but Hassan didn't know that to catch him on
it. So, he just moved on. He's slimy. I mean, he's a he's a troll
clearly, right? But, you know, and and the one thing I don't
like to defend Ethan a little bit, like the one thing I don't
like is how like Hassan and like none of these people that watch
Bad Empanada's videos, like they'll never admit like what bad
empanada is or who he is as a person, like the terrible [__]
he's done. They'll always like play ignorant, be like, "What?
I'm just watching a video. Who cares?" You know, they'll never
admit like, "Yeah, this guy is like the number one thorn in Ethan's
side." like they'll never like actually like be honest about
like the the type of character that he is. Has um before Han
started watching stuff, he was saying how insane he was. And
then now that watches stuff, he says something like, "Oh, we've
got differences in tactics. I don't think all the stuff he does
is good, this sort of stuff." That's that's usually how he handles
it. I don't think he just totally ignores it. Well, well, still
even still to that point, it's like he doesn't admit that like
he's playing the video because he's like, "This is the craziest
that, you know, really will piss Ethan off." You know, he always
like is like, "Oh, this guy's fine." Or, well, I don't know if
he says that, but you know, it's kind of like just because there's
the craziest guy that will piss Ethan Ethan off. I don't think
Australian plays videos. I think they are like um Are they good?
They're quite popular and um you know, they are watchable at
least like he's not a bad content creator if you know what I
mean, right? Are his videos good against Ethan? Like his critiques,
they're mixed. Sometimes he just like will just run with something
because he knows he can. Um, some some of them are better time
the stuff that he sources. Like, you know, sometimes you can't
trust exactly what he says, but like the source might be good.
Like, you know, it's like, "Oh, I didn't know that clip existed."
That sort of thing. Well, like again to the Nick Fuentes comparison,
like Nick Fuentes like probably has a lot of good information
in the Middle East, but like he obviously has like a bench or
like an agenda. Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. Exactly. So, it's like
the same thing where it's like he might have like good information
or like knowledge on the topic, but he clearly has like a very
like devious bent to it, you know. I will say the only bad videos
I've ever watched is like his Xanderhal
Xander is just so funny to me. The Cameron F5 video went hard
when he the whole time. He made a video on Cameron. Yeah, dude.
I need to watch that. That's crazy. Yeah. I feel like he I watched
also his video on like the Billy Mitchell drama and stuff which
is very funny to me that he was just covering that at all. But
yeah, it was good. Just look, did you skim through this article?
No, I've not skimmed through it. I was trying to get these avatars
working. For some reason, Auggie isn't working with my uh overlay.
I have no idea why. Wait, you have like a picture drawn for me.
Uh yeah, I've got a guy in my audience who does runs this like
really fast. Wait, this is crazy. Who he drew this tonight? Well,
I mean, he uses like impaint and like AI to make stuff, but yeah,
he
I just noticed I have one. It's so cute. It looks cool as Yeah,
Auggie the there's supposed to be a speaking face, too. When
you speak, it's supposed to switch to this, but here, hold on.
I'll uh I'll move you in and move you out and maybe it'll Dude,
this looks awesome, though. I don't even Yo, let's see. Sorry,
I moved you and moved you out. See if that'll fix the overlay.
Oh, yeah. Nice. Dude, this looks awesome. What the Why are you
a frog? Why are you Why are you Kermit? Uh, I don't know. Uh,
we have I have Muppets for people. He sounds like Kermit the
Frog cuz he's Canadian. Yeah. Also, I sound like Kermit the Frog.
Did you guys see Blox's Only Fans link tonight? His official
Only Fans. The official Bolex Only Fans. No, stop. I I tweeted
on Twitter that I was going to dox anyone that sends me like
the videos from that page. I sent Aiden a picture of Bolexes
when those dropped. You did
[__] I mean, he deserves it, but that's still sick
as that is terrible. Is Blowbacks, y'all, how do you Is it blow
blacks or blowbacks? It's Bo Black. Bo Blacks. In his Only Fans
bio, it said Blowbacks.
That's how he typed it. Oh, okay. Is he like Boax? Yeah. Boax.
Well, Bo Tommy C says Bo backs. This person is like the new Christine
Weston Chandler to me. Tommy D. Why are you guys so mean to Tommy
C? He's a good guy. Yeah, he's a good guy. Kind of a good guy.
Total unforced error. Just I I got to be honest. On a live stream
just out of nowhere. I fully plan to review the Chud Lodge drama.
I haven't like died. You're laziest. I saw you tweet like two
weeks ago. I'm streaming next week. Like, okay, man. Dude, I'm
I'm a very busy guy. What can I say? You know, but uh Yeah. Why
you guys Well, okay. I don't want to talk about the current drama.
Like, why are you guys hate him in the first place? Like, what
what's wrong with them? I hate Tommy C in the first place. Yeah.
Um, why do I hate Tony? I don't I didn't really hate him. I don't
even really hate him now, you know? It's just like he's just
really dumb.
His commentary is just really bad. He's got unearned confidence.
He has this whole um like uncle dynamic with Nick where he's
like you know sees Nick as like this little baby bird that he's
raised up and allowed to leave the nest and uh he has just protect
him all the time and takes his word as as lucarium sight like
oh well well Nick thinks Nick thinks Nick thinks every five seconds
when live stream he does do that a lot dude I got to be honest
I watched bro Tommy sees like basically the reason why I stream
as like that might be like a horrible thing to admit. I know
you guys did what was it that Instagram [__] or something
and Tommy say you for or some [__] like that. No,
no, no. Okay. Well, first of all, that was like the one time
me and Tommy were ever fighting. He completely screwed me over
in that situation. By the way, I was totally in the right. I
had all these like losers come on and admit to the up of ring
and then everyone that covered it was like auggie ring. And I'm
like, "No, I brought the people on and questioned them about
it and held them accountable for what they did to it up." And
for some reason, I got blamed for the whole situation. Even though
I was never involved, I got over in that situation. But, uh,
dude, no, before that, dude, Tommy, see, he's a, you know, he's
a commentary OG. He comes from a different time, you know. He's
uh, yeah, sometimes you got to take the dog, our old dog out
back. I I have people saying that I need to give him a me and
Nick need to give him a fireside chat. Is that I again I need
to review the Chudlo Logic. I haven't seen it. I I know he's
like upset at Chudlogic. Um probably cuz you go after him. I
assume. I don't know. Well, yeah, but I mean the the justification
is like the New Year's stream basically.
The best was he blamed Chud for all of the New Year's stream
and then we had to go review it and it's like all you starting
by. Yeah. Well, okay. I was going to see you say that. It's like
I was at my behavior on that stream was atrocious. Like I basically
did every Sench did like at the same time. Totestin death tot
destiny death. That was it. Okay. Every there was like there
was like three things in that stream. It was like the Destiny
conversation.
Uh there was there was Bax and then there was Kinetic Kell and
it's like I instigated all three of those conversations. Dude,
the Kinetic Kell the neck. That was awesome,
dude. Oh man, I I kind of felt bad for that because I was like
I was like that I was gonna be I was kind of being a little bit
gay on that whole thing. But it was funny, dude. It was good.
But no, it's like I did everything like why why am I not getting
the same amount of um cuz you're one of the boys and Chud's not.
Ch's on the outs. Willy Max said Willy Max said that Orgie's
okay, but Chud's not. So Tommy's actually on the Did he say that?
Uh no, he didn't say that. I'm just assuming Tommy C said it.
So it means Willie or Nick said it basically thought he's got
no sensient thoughts. W
we love the uh the twisting there. Tommy does say a lot of the
time he's like I told it's like he kind of confirmed some of
the memes where it's just like we were talking about this guy
in the group chat. We were talking about this thing in the group
chat. I was talking with like these guys about this thing the
other day. It's like why why are you why would you what were
they talking the group chat? Well,
but they were they were talking amongst themselves basically
um about Willie and Tommy were having conversations about how
Chud's a snake because Chud
Willie was responding to the criticism of his first Destiny video,
if you remember all that stuff. Uh Chud messaged Willie and said,
"Hey Willie, heard you're crashing out. Do you want to come on
stream and talk to people about it or have a conversation about
it?" And Willie took that to be Chud snaking him, I guess, farming
him for content. Yeah. And Willie was upset about that and told
Tommy, I mean, you know, my criticism won't be like super accurate
cuz I barely remember this. I remember agreeing with your original
criticisms. You guys like
in that debate about the first video, right? I remember the debate.
Yeah. Yeah, I remember the debate, of course. But like you guys
went on Willie for like a while. I do remember after that debate,
you guys were like very hard on Willie after that. I don't know
if that was like I don't know if that was like deserved or not,
but I remember it was. What did he do after that whole situation?
Why did that continue for so long? Well, he just kept acting
like a [__] He was on Twitter arguing down with people
like 50 replies deep with morale. Um and he was just saying like
the most un Wasn't it like the next day though, like after the
debate? Um, it happened for like it was for like at least three
days after he came on my stream and then it's been he is like
on endless like snide comments here and there. Um, was he not
allowed to have like
distaste of you after you covered for so long? You can have distaste.
Talk about it though. Say it with your chest. Defend it. Don't
do some snide because I'm here. I'm willing to talk to Willie
Mack anytime. Willie Mack just isn't willing to put up and face
any criticism. That that's the issue. He won't sit there and
make snide remarks and say, "Oh, J and Queen should be grateful
that I put Destiny's death right to them in my video cuz it warms
them." It's like, "Okay, okay, you are like actually you have
a mental disability." Or he's saying like, "I I take um firstand
evidence to be better than secondhand evidence." And what he
means by that is I prefer talking to people involved rather than
getting screenshots from the internet. Even though obviously
one is external evidence that can be verified and the other one
is just testimony. Just like the the most absolutely things that
you cannot in in good conscience claim to be like some you know
researcher who owns Hassan for getting everything wrong and epically
debunks people all the time while saying that just betrays that
you have a fundamental lack of understanding of like how to process
evidence and like read a situation. Interesting. Yeah. So he
I remember like one thing he said was like Destiny had made some
comment about how he wanted he wanted to like shoot you guys
or kill you guys or something like that and Willie was like that's
he went on more than that said he wanted to like there was like
a whole gay fantasy about slicing your balls off thing. Yeah,
that that made it into it. It talked about cutting the balls
off or some that's crazy. And Willie was like, "That's awesome."
or something like that. Willy Willie basically said um just laughed.
He he said, "I don't care that this happened because Quimman
said he wants to stomp Yeet into the dirt," which is obviously
me talking like we got to destroy this guy. It's not me saying
I want to go to Yeet's house and shoot him in the head. That's
obviously not why I'm saying that. Yeah. Um, so he just drew
a false equivalency and then said, "Well, so I don't care." So
it's like, "Okay." He'll just swipe. I think he said, "I should
care." I think the direct quote was something like, "I should
care about this, but I find these guys really annoying." Or some
like that. He's like, "These guys are so annoying that I don't
really care that Destiny threatened them, that he wished for
their death." That to me that like first impression that comes
off as like honest though. It's like, you know, he he feels he's
like, "I should be against this, but I [__] I hate
these guys." mind if it's just that but I think and pretending
that Yeah. Also, dude. Yeah. Lad about skulls
us you. Yeah. Okay. I heard you guys say sweeping. This is like
a different discussion. Do you guys think like Turkey Tom swept
for Destiny like back in the day? Cuz I've heard this before
and I've never understood this argument cuz I always felt like
Tom like distanced himself like before like this came out. But
no 100%. He sweat for Destiny. just like go watch his like Destiny
documentary. It's like the most like the IRL video he made. Yeah.
Yeah. Um like he does he there are like so I mean I don't know
how associated you ever were Destiny. It seems like Nick and
Tom at least compromised serious positions to hang out with this
guy. I don't feel like it would be cool by Nick and Tom's usual
standards that they would lay out in like videos and live streams
to be hanging out with someone who knowingly at the age of like
26 messaged a 15year-old girl got photos from her said about
how it was so hard to say no talked about how massive to her
and sent the photos around his group chat talking about you know
what wanted her basically
I remember I I knew about that situation cuz I used to watch
the kumate back in the Yeah. Yeah. I used that was on the Kumate.
I used to watch that show. And did he know the girl's age or
Yeah. Yes. Yeah. He knew he doubled down on it multiple conversations
after. Well, I remember like after the DM at some point he learned
her age and then like after 100% at the time of conversation
at the time of conversation. Okay. Cuz I remember at some point
he figured the age and then he was like he has a message where
he was like like it's so hard to like say no sometimes. But yeah,
that that was the point is he's saying like but she was 15. Dude,
it was so hard to say no. That's his quote when he's talking
to his friends afterwards. So, at some point in that conversation,
he knows she's 15. She wants to Yes. say no. Damn. And so, yeah.
I mean, yeah, that is hard to defend. The thing is like I remember
like I watched that back at the time, but then like I don't know.
I guess I just didn't care cuz Destiny was making good content
at the time. So, I was like, "Not who cares?" Yeah. It's one
thing to watch the guy, but when you're going to make a video
doing like doing a documentary on him and it's like you're just
like sucking and you don't like ask him about that and like press
him super well. I mean it's not it's not even that. It's like
Tom would take a strong like condemnation stance on that with
other people, but there is not a condemnation where he's like
this guy's a piece of on Destiny. Nor is there for, you know,
any of the politically radical speech that Destiny's engaged
in that, you know, Nick now claims to have an issue with when
it comes to Hassan. you know, Destiny saying the the um firefighter
stuff happened before any of them sort of cut off. Um there's
uh accusing President Sunday and donut operator of being with
no evidence which hit minimal criticism. Um there was man like
threatened DOS kid. There's the endless examples of doxing. There's
the um fact that in Turkey Tom's video he literally just totally
skims over the Mr. Destiny report and say it says, "Oh, well,
everyone says there's nothing to this, so I don't really care
about it." Basically, is the gist of what he says about it. When
if he'd actually looked into it, he would have found out more
information about, you know, how Destiny was essentially abusive
towards Anna and um Mhm. Anna was perfectly happy to talk about
that stuff. By the way, talk about that. Yeah. Yeah. So, like
there there's just a laundry list of things that were ignored
that would usually uh set off like the alarms or the I I would
have a problem with this alarms to all to I think a lot of commentary
creators that that were just totally happy to like hang out with
him. Willie, Tom, Nick. Yeah. Interesting. Yeah, I know about
some of that stuff. Um the firefighter like kid with the that
he threatened to kill or whatever or sorry, there's two situations.
There's like one situation where like he threatened to kill the
kid that was DDoSing him. I kind of sympathize with him on that
take cuz I don't know. Okay, but here's the thing. You realize
like the solution to that was literally stop using Skype and
use Ventrillo instead, right? Was it a Skype only issue? Yeah.
Yes. Interest. Oh, I thought he was dodosing him on Twitch. No,
he was there was a way you could grab people's play Starcraft
via Skype and if you added them to your friends list, you would
get their IP or some interesting. Okay. Cuz I've had people like
So I've had similar situations where people would just like spend
all day long just like flagging my YouTube channel and like every
day I'd try to go live like I just wouldn't be able to stream
on my YouTube because people would just be constantly sending
in like false reports and stuff. Yeah. And I have felt that murderous
rage, you know. I'm not going to lie. Like I have I have felt
that before. So when I saw that situation even about streets,
no, I didn't go that far. But I as far as I went, it was just
like deming my friends being like, "Oh, I want to kill this guy."
But it's like you know I have felt that like sensation before
but it's like so when I heard about that on you know the kumite
and stuff like that I was kind of like okay I kind of I sympathize
with this a lot but it's easy to empathize with but I mean it's
just like if you interrogate the actual story it's just like
it's like the idea that you were like cuz he doesn't just defend
feeling that way. He defends the act of going killing him in
theory. Right. Yeah. Well he defends it as if he was like planning
to do that. Yeah. He said he was planning to do it multiple times
that he was planning to do it and he's doubled down saying he
never the exact gun that he bought. No, wasn't it the first?
Yeah. And he said he literally got his firearms license to do
that, you know, everything like absolutely. So, but it's just
an issue of use ventrillo, don't use Skype and that that was
it. But he has somehow convinced everyone convinced the entire
commentary community for years that actually no, he was just
being he had no other choice. He had to go and kill this kid.
That's just not true. Right. Yeah. Yeah, I remember hearing about
the story in my mind. I was just like, ah, I've wanted to kill
people that my channel, so it you know, you know, but it's Yeah,
I see what you're saying there. There's the other thing like
the the moment where I turn on Destiny. This might be a soy argument
for me, but it was the firefighter kid. Like I know you guys
are probably pro that stuff, right? Like where about that really?
Yeah. Yeah.
Or fighters or anything, so I'm like very like [__]
from a business perspective. I think he burned a bunch of connections.
He didn't have to burn.
I don't like it either. Well, that's fair. But like I I just
remember like when he was like, "I don't give a about this guy
dying and like I remember I was like arguing with Aiden about
this like one night or something and Aiden was like if you have
like political positions like it's okay to like be fond of you
being I don't see that. I mean I can see it's like funny and
base but it's like that's awesome. I don't know. I don't know.
I just like I I can just see like the problem is I just see like
my you know grandpa or something just being like a MAGA boomer
and it's like would I be fine with him being like just gunned
down just because he likes Trump like you know and and Aiden
kept bringing up like oh well he had tweets on his account like
so like Ukraine stuff and I'm like so he had a bad take like
who the cares right like I'd say at least from Desi's perspective
there he did say he'd be fine with his parents getting gunned
down at a similar thing. Well see that's psychotic to me that's
psychotic to me too. I like that. That's just the kind of stuff
that I'm just like that doesn't make it better. But I
if he's consistent, you know, it's like the people who would
like uh applaud that. Like I understand the consistency there,
but it's like I you're just totally inhuman. You're like a lizard.
I
Well, I mean, he just blocked his son on Twitter. To me, that's
inhuman, you know? Like I don't know. Uh that might be a kindness,
but Well, it depends like why he blocked him. Maybe it's cuz
he blocked his son cuz he's like, "Holy, you're going a little
bit." Have you guys seen Destiny's son's Twitter recently
about that? Yeah, we try not to do that as well. Yeah. Okay.
Is that a bad Sometimes. Well, like sometimes there are things
that are just so funny, but yeah, I just try not to. I've discovered
it today and and learned that he followed me. I didn't know that.
And I didn't know whether to like soft block or or what. I'm
pretty sure he's a minor and I felt like it was it feels weird,
but I didn't do anything. Yeah. No, that's fair. I mean, yeah.
Yeah. But no, I saw that. But um yeah, I don't know. Like his
take of like, oh, I don't give a my parents for like just gunned
alive on a Trump rally just because they support Trump. I'm like
50% of the country supports Trump, you know? Like to me that's
a crazy position to hold. But I don't know. It's like you're
cool with like 50% of the country just being gunned down just
because they like Trump. Not even like I don't even think like
everyone that likes I think when it came down to his argument
wasn't just that if you're a passive Trump suppressor if you're
going to rallies like you're showing active support to Trump
then then you're a fair target but at that point you are basically
just saying like what they then like a Twitter post okay like
you go and hunt someone down for a proTrump Twitter post like
what are we saying at this point? Everything breaks down if you're
going to let people target each other for political speech. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. But like if if well that's the that's an interesting
distinction cuz like if you go to a proTrump rally does that
mean that you endorse like you're super first of all that you're
super cognizant of every position that Trump holds or every position
you must hold as a MAGA voter. Yes Dy's position. Yeah. Well
here's the thing right. So I saw like commentary commentary swept
super hard for that take. I do agree with that. Um, this is before
I even returned to the internet, but of course I still saw that
[__] And so I was I remember like DMing Dior and
I was just like, "What the why is everyone supporting this? If
Hassan said the same thing, everyone would be up his ass." You
know, Hassan said like America deserved 9/11, which I think is
actually a much more defensible position than like the Destiny
firefighter thing. Uh, but Destiny says this and everyone just
like immediately like is totally like understanding of nuance
and everything and they they can sort of defend like where he's
going with that. I just thought it was ridiculous to me. So that's
kind of when I turned on Destiny when I was just like, "All right,
if this was the song saying it, if this was Ethan Klein saying
it, cuz remember at the time Ethan Klein was very disliked by
commentary." Yeah. I mean, everyone would have like lost their
[__] So, I don't know. That's kind of when I turned,
but then the revenge stuff came out and I was like, "Yeah, this
guy is just a loser." I don't know. But
it's
sharing of sexual telemetry. Oh, what did you say, Queen? I said
it's not reven it's nonentual sharing of sure you get terms right
glasses pushes up glasses true you mean like the the brutal that
destin exactly dude people getting mad over the thing Tommy hates
the as well Tommy I did I did see that part like I was like I've
literally I have a tweet that has like 30,000 likes on Twitter
calling Destiny a for that whole situation like how the people
who are criticizing this Yeah, dude. 30,000 people like that.
I'm like, there's no way Tommy didn't see this. Like the I don't
know. I think it's fair to call Well, I mean, I don't think he's
literally like a But like I think it's, you know, it's a form
of consent violation. Yeah. Well, I that's what I felt like the,
you know, the the commentary was is like he doesn't care about
a woman's consent, you know, in this context. So, it's like you
can say that about him and it's not that crazy. He's spiritually.
Yeah, exactly. I try not to be hyperbolic about him. I wanted
to respond just like absolutely spiritually and like as he continues
to commit bad acts. He loses his beard and his hairline and looks
more and more like a like every day. Yeah. I haven't been following
him recently. Have you you've been covering like the the court
stuff? Like what's been going on with that lately? Has he been
um I mean is he like just completely destroying Pixie and Core?
Like what's going on there? Uh it's basically like it it sort
of like bogged down in Pixie wanted to basically block him from
talking about the case as much on social media and it bogged
down in like a hearing over that. So, it's been like that's basically
been all of it. And through that, somebody came forward who said
they were sent a video of Pix Pixie in November of 2024. And
Desi's previous argument to that had been or sorry, videos of
Pixie, like the same videos that got released, I think. And Desi's
argument to that previously was you can't sue me under this law
cuz it started in October of 2023 and I sent the videos in April
of 2023 or 2022, whatever. I think it's 2022. Um, yeah. So, it's
like he sent the he sent the videos like 8 months before the
law came into effect, so he can't sue me. Um, and then a woman
came forward and said, "No, no, no. I was sent the Pixie video
after this date." And they have logs like telling their friends
about these videos, but not cuz Destiny deleted his messages.
They don't have the actual messages from Destiny. Right. And
so
cope after that. A woman different than like the person in the
leaks. Yeah. Well, I mean, we're going to say we can literally
say Pixie cuz she's named in the lawsuit and stuff. Oh, okay.
Oh, it's pixie or Okay. Okay, I see where you're going. But um
but yeah, this woman came forward and said like I was sent these
log or sorry, I was sent these videos and here's logs, Discord
logs of me talking about it. And I still have these logs. I have
like screenshots of these logs and it's like basically contemporaneous
evidence for in March of I think it's March of 2023,
she was talking about videos that you don't learn about until
November of 2024. Yeah. So it's like how the did she know about
these? But now Destiny's basically said that like now he's trying
to cope and say like oh well she went through my computer and
found all these videos actually and so that's how she knows about
them and it's like why does that what does that matter like how
she found them sent them? Wait, say that again. It mean it seems
to have been like sent them or something, right? It can't just
have been the computer. Yeah, cuz the allegation isn't that they
were recorded non-conensually. It's that they were shared non-consensually.
Yeah. But this the same woman Oh, so she found them on his computer
but just on like the hard
He says that he's but like he has no evidence of that that I've
seen. He hasn't introduced any evidence of that in court. So
I would love to see any evidence of that potentially. Well, I
mean wouldn't that be like proving a negative like how like proving
that he didn't send them or something? Or am I missing something
here? Uh it wouldn't be proving that he didn't send them. It
would give a like plausible deniability, like another possible
explanation for how she'd know about those videos. Cuz otherwise,
she basically guessed two women that appeared in non-consensual
uh audio or video with him. And she she guessed these names before
anybody could have known about them. Okay. And she didn't guess
any non-names. She didn't guess like, oh, it's like this person
or this person. She guessed like actual people who were in some
of the leaks. Yeah. And so it's like, well, why did she tell
somebody that she was sent videos super recklessly by Destiny
um of people that she recognizes from the stream and then those
videos later came to actually we we found out they exist through
another leak. Yeah. So it's like it's I don't know. It's uh probably
going to go to Discovery, I think. I don't know if he'll win
or lose. It'll depend on if they can find probably like real
evidence of him having sent those videos again. And realistically,
if he deleted them soon enough, uh that evidence might not exist
anymore. So interesting. Okay. You might get out of the Pixie
lawsuit. Uh kind of scot-free. Other people have lawsuits. I
don't know if those are ever going to move forward. I have no
idea. A lot of people are just like, "Yeah, I don't want the
harassment from this guy. I'd rather just move on." Yeah. Well,
I mean, he's got like a really like highprofile lawyer working
with him too, right? Like, yeah, the guy who was the lawyer for
Prince Andrew. Yeah. Andy B. Andrew Breler. That's crazy. Yeah.
He got the he got the lawyer. The guy who makes me Yeah. The
victim blamer. Um, yeah. So, I don't know. It's like it could
I really don't know how it would go and I assume that if you
if it's like a tossup that that kind of goes to the defendant,
right? So, so have any like legal YouTubers been covering this?
Like all the Nick Reca Orbiter guys, have any of them been covering
this? Potentially criminals done a couple of them. I think because
of where it's like bogged down, they try to only do like updates
once in a while. Yeah. Um, yeah. It's just like it's going to
take a little bit. We'll get the ruling on this like what they
call like a preliminary injunction soon. Legal mindset did look
at it before. I don't think he's looked at it recently. Um, all
of them looked at it like initially and then I don't know if
they've all looked at it recently, but stuff just is moving forward
slowly because of this preliminary injunction hearing. So, we
just haven't seen I think they're also battling each other in
discovery like a lot. Like they wanted uh Destiny's like Google
Drive history for the past 5 years or something and he's like
fighting that. He said he'd rather kill himself than give that
up. And interesting. Yeah. Yeah, I mean there's probably I guess
I can see why he would not want to show that. I don't know. I
don't know if that's weird or not to like restrict showing that,
but
um I mean he definitely wouldn't want it made public in any way.
And I think it would have to be like lawyers going through it
and determining what could be relevant to the case, right? Yeah.
Legal mindset. I only know who that guy is cuz Ethan Ralph did
like a really funny rant on him once. Lady boy mindset. Lady
sucker. More like it. I don't know who that guy is. What' you
think about the Ethan lawsuit? Okay. Uh E which Ethan lawsuit?
The React lawsuits.
Oh, we were talking about that earlier. Yeah, I can't support
it. I don't know. I feel like uh you have to be like support
this, especially as like a React streamer. Have you Have you
like actually looked into like um No, I haven't watched Ethan
Klein's video or read the lawsuit. I've I've I've so I know Connor's
looked into it. He told me a little bit about it and base one.
He told me or whatever. It sounded like complete
uh
he's very like neutral on like commentary stuff like he he's
he's more so like you know let's see both sides but he was telling
me he was like yeah like this is like turning on Ethan worthy
level and he was telling me a lot about it like the denim stuff
specifically. I mean I was talking about that a lot before like
you came in here but yeah it seems like pretty stupid to uh support
that. I I don't like the president that it could set. I don't
like uh who he's even going after. At least with Denims, I feel
like the Denim's case, I got I was so glad that Connor took over
Twitter versus cuz like Bolex can't even express his own opinion.
So the idea that he's going to be able to sit through and pick
out both sides of an argument on Twitter and present them like
relatively fairly is like that's that's a totally insurmountable
task for this. Yeah, the Connor actually I've been surprised
several times. was like, "Wow, this would be very easy to just
form like a safe stance on this." But no, it is actually kind
of both sides. I'm I'm always shocked seeing that in Twitter
versus Yeah. I mean, like to me, like the I don't really watch
much Twitter versus or internet versus like to me the format
is very just like you just relay the tweets from both sides.
Yeah. No, I watch like if I'm like super invested in a topic
and I've got nothing else to cover on it, I'll pull that up on
stream and it's like, you know, does he actually give his opinion
there? No, but you know, the opinion comes through. Boax's opinion
always came through in Twitter versus. Do you know what I mean?
Like you could always tell which side Bob was on from Twitter
versus cuz he's capable of like fairly presenting the sides.
It was like depending on which tweets he shows for me. Exactly.
It's always just like here's a bunch of EP epic sick owns for
my side and it's like saying his voice. But Connor is more like
I've noticed like more there are actual points from tweets on
on both sides. you know, there'll be someone making an argument
and they'll present someone making the counter argument like
stuff like that where it's like, "Oh my god, thank there's actually
some like uh you know, effort put in." Well, I mean, like that's
how me and Connor like so me and Connor like did RFC show for
a little bit and then back in 2023, we did like Red Foxcoms where
we just did like 10-minute commentary videos and like whatever
the trending topic was. We love just like looking at the topic
and just like actually thinking about it critically and seeing
like, okay, where are both sides coming from? where do we stand
on this? Blah blah blah, stuff like that. I feel like nobody
does that. I feel like people are just like, "Okay, what's the
side? What's the pick?" You know, where we where are we uh what's
the move here? And it's just it's much more it's much more fun
to analyze drama when you're just looking at it like just okay,
what do we actually think about this and rather than just Yeah,
exactly. Just go and let me know exactly what you're going to
say before you even look at it. Yeah. Oh, no. It's it's brutal,
dude. when I make anti Ethan Klein videos or antan tweets or
even like when me and Connor used to do our like daily commentary
channel back in like 2023, our channel would not grow because
we kept like switching sides every video. Not because we were
like grifting or anything, but just because like every time we'd
make a video about like an ongoing topic is Yeah, perfect. Yeah,
exactly. So, we couldn't really grow. Yeah, exactly. That's the
growth mechanism is when you're just the dick. Yeah. When you're
on one side. That's why we quit the channel ultimately. It's
just because like it just wasn't like sustainable for growth.
So,
but uh yeah, and it's so stupid to me because the content's so
much more funnier. Like if I'm subbing to a channel and I never
know what their take is going to be on something, that's like
super interesting to me cuz it's like, oh, like I actually am
getting like a surprise every time I come. If something is too
predictable, if something is too predictable, I would just stop
watching. Yeah, it's like that easy. Like I I probably would
still occasionally click on a Destiny video. I don't I don't
know to be honest cuz I'm just disgusted by the side of him at
this point. But I might still occasionally video if I didn't
like know 100% exactly what this guy was going to say every time.
Like I Why would I ever look at his coverage of Assan? Why would
I ever look at his coverage of Ethan Klein? This guy is completely
bought in. Why would I ever look at, you know, Eerodite's coverage
of Destiny, for instance, other than just like rip it apart on
stream obviously? Like if I was if I was off stream, why why
would I ever go go and watch something like that when I know
exactly what it's going to be? Why would I sit through an hour
and a half of something that I can basically write in my head
before I go and click on it? Well, it's funny cuz that's the
same thing he says about you guys. Like that recent clip of him,
he's like, "You guys are just antiubs
against me." Yeah, exactly. It's crazy. But no, it's like that
should be like what people are thirsting for. They should be
thirsting for a commentary channel that's like you never know
what they're going to say. You know, they could have a take on
anything. They could be like pro Ethan one day and then Aunt
Ethan the next day. You never know. But you know that their take
is genuine and something that they really believe in, not something
that's like, oh well, this is the uh you know, this is the the
take. This is the take on something. And the problem is is that
creators are not incentivized to have unique takes in anything.
Not just because it's harder to defend those takes. Like I always
thought the reason why creators like didn't have like unique
takes on something is just because like it's harder to defend.
But no, I know this firsthand from making content. The reason
why creators don't have unique takes and [__] is
because you don't [__] grow from having a unique
take. You just stagnate yourself. You don't make as much money.
You can't. It's just you need like flashoint moments, right?
Like you have to grow off of big fights with like bigger creators
and it's way less sustainable. It's so you have to grow fights,
but it's like if you're a creator that just wants to have a unique
take, but you're not I don't want like for instance like I'm
not really like a big debater guy. Like I don't necessarily want
to have like a 5 hour debate every time I make a video, right?
But I feel like you have to do that because you need like that
huge moment, you know, of like, oh, this is where they stood
up. If you want Yeah. If you want to be unique, you definitely
have to. I think you have to do that. It's very hard to just
be unique, have unique takes, and have people like gravitate
to them. But you have to be unique, but also be like online like
20 to like grow at all. Otherwise, you can just have unique takes,
but nobody cares because they just want that this they want a
very safe take regurgitated to them, you know? That's why like
even in politics, it's like all the top creators on the left
and the right are like the most like [__] sloth like
bare bones like type of people. So that's Brian Tyler Cohen or
like Yeah. Yeah. It's like Dean Withers or Charlie Kirk. It's
like the people that are actually like interesting like you know
they're not really doing anything like numbers wise. It's sad
but uh yeah you guys seeing this picture on screen right now.
Guess this I I just feel like when is this guy going to stop
winning? Oh, Auggie is going to hate this take, isn't he? When
is this guy going to stop winning? This is apparently the guy
who just won the NYC primary. Okay. Oh my god. hanging out with
Hassan.
Wow. This is the guy that Sneo endorsed. Yes. Imagine being such
a prolific political influencer that you could get a mayor elected
or through a primary in a city. Okay. Destiny. Destiny could
never. All right. Destiny could never. Oh, you What do you mean,
dude? Sne Dude, Sneo put in all the work, dude. Like, uh, he's
a Sneo's an NYC resident, you know? Obviously, it was all his
influence that won him this. I don't even know this guy's policies.
Like why is like I know he's Muslim. That's it. He's a democratic
socialist part of the DSA. Oh, look who's in the replies. I didn't
even see our buddy over in the replies. Let me move the chat
for you guys. Mr. Dan can't stream over here. Not liking the
Hassan support for Zoron. Total lie again. He's even wearing
a 9/11 truther shirt. What is it? Paradise.
Steel beams. It says about jet fuel melting steel beams, but
it's a t-shirt that about conspiracies. So it's like the joke
is that it's a conspiracy.
Yeah. You hate to see it. Simultaneously America deserve 911
and it was an inside job. Okay. So he believes both those things
simultaneously.
Let's go. Oh man.
Oh, I forgot that. Um Yeah. Also, Anthony Weiner's election was
tonight and he got demolished. He didn't even get 10% of the
vote. God. Her pervert alert. Yeah. Well, I don't know if you
did you see him. He was on like the Adam Freeland show. He's
running for like councilman in New York City. He ran for the
[__] councilman of the second council district. City
member of city council. Second council district. Democratic.
Oh, is this just a primary then? And he lost. He got destroyed
in a primary with like less than 10,000 votes. This guy was This
guy was in the House of Representatives. Anthony Weiner. He got
1,000 votes. He lost to a guy named Harvey Epstein.
Dude, that's Wow.
That's nuts. That's awesome. That is messed up, man. He got beat
by bigger pervert. Pervert alert. Wild. Oh
god. Yeah. I saw Sneo endorsed the New York City guy and everyone
was super mad at him. I had people in my community like they
were like we need to like in Sneo or something. I'm like I I
don't even know this guy's policies. New York I mean New York
City I hear it's a I've never been so I don't I
don't know. That's the Democratic primary I think. Right. So
I think he wants
Yeah. So it's if it's a Democrat, he's going to be New York City
is going to be a bigger I guess. I don't know. Well, no. No,
but like I don't think the Dems don't automatically win, right?
Like the current one is a Republican candidate. That's Eric Adams,
right? Is he like impeached or something? Why? I feel like he
just got voted in. Um he crazy he did a deal with Trump to not
get charged with a crime, right? Did he? Okay. Yeah. Basically,
Trump Trump basically let it slide because he allowed ICE to
come into New York. Well, I wonder if uh I wonder if Adams is
Adams like automatically the candidate for like the Republicans
or something. I don't even know. I don't know how go about becoming
mayor of New York City. Oh, he's a It says he's Democratic. What
the I don't I don't know how their elections work. He's independent.
Okay. Weird. His Wikipedia page says he's uh it says that he's
Democrat in terms of affiliation, but I guess in New York he
must run independent. He was Dem. Okay. All right.
All right. You guys got anything else you want to throw out?
I'm probably going to end here pretty good. I'm chilling. I'm
sorry I kept your stream going all night long, but uh it was
uh No, no, it was awesome discussion actually coming to a natural
end here. So, yeah, definitely. It's good hanging out. Good hanging
out with you guys. Good catching up talking about Ethan Klein,
the commentary, Cabal War. Uh you guys need to lay up Tommy C.
He's nice. Okay, when you uh when you going live? Uh I'll be
going live very soon covering the the conflict, the war, right?
But yeah, no, I mean uh you guys need to lay up Tommy C. He's
a very nice old. Okay, you guys need to uh respect your elders
more. He's a good guy. I literally can't cover any more of the
the Tommy C stuff. It's like so boring and repetitive at this
point. He's getting He he has taken the knee off of his neck
by just being too boring to chug to death, you know. Damn. He
owned you. He became too boring for you to cover. He won. I didn't
even
started mentioning.
I don't know why he he started talking about me cuz I'm like
I stream with Queen. So I I feel like you don't really involve
yourself in commentary drama that much, but like you get mentioned
all the time as like cuz people just see you as like Queman's
like second in something. Yeah, people are mad at Queman and
then they just they throw my name into and I I just happen to
be basically the same thing. I don't even know. Maybe that's
fair. Maybe that's a fair argument to make. I don't know. Maybe
you are nice to everybody all of the time. I'm literally nice
to all of these people. Uh when I'm not nice, I apologize and
I say, "Hey, why don't we be friends again?" You know, here's
my position on spicy chat. You know, I like them because they're
very nice to me. But as soon as they become mean to me, which
I know they will because you guys are mean to all of my friends.
As soon as you guys become mean to me, then I would become very
afraid. But uh as of right now, they're very cool. I don't know.
That's my position. Oh, based I don't see why people have to
even Scary chat room. Very scary.
Yeah. Crazy. That's my position to everybody. It's like they're
very nice to me and then when they become mean, I become very
scared and then I move on. So, you know, it is what it is. You'll
always have a place here. Okay. This will always be a neutral
ground where you can talk about whatever.
Yeah, totally. Neutral ground. You guys are going to snake me
one day. I know it. I know it. Tommy, I' I've been inflicted
with all a ball paranoia. I know it's going to happen. How do
you How do you snake people by literally on a public stream saying
what the criticisms are and then asking them if they want to
talk? This is like the most snake- like behavior. Well, you got
to craft the criticisms, right? You got to like come up with
like the reason. It's like why? How do we snake this guy in a
way where it looks like it's not snaking? You know, legendary
stuff. Yeah, you guys crafted your reason. You guys were like,
Tommy, see, he's old. He's He's drunk. He's uh he's gay. What
do you guys hate Tommy C for again? He's drunk. He's old. He's
all drunk and and gay. I'm [__] Exactly. Exactly.
You guys will one day you guys come up with a reason for everyone.
Willie Mack, you know, he's uh Willie Mack. He uh he shields
for Destiny. Turkey Tommy shields for Destiny. You guys keep
coming after all my friends. You guys got to chill and uh bow
down and accept the Cabal narrative on everything. So true. Kiss
the ring. Kiss the ring. You guys got to Okay, you guys got to
understand uh this is my closing statement. Uh Dioro always wins.
Okay, every battle Dior has always won. You guys got to be careful.
Pick the right side every single time from He picks the right
side. He picks the right side. And uh you know I feel sorry for
anyone that's on the other side. You know
not not a good indication. Yeah it's it's rough out there. All
right I think I'm going to rate relevant guys. We will talk to
you all tomorrow. Okay. Go say hi to Relly and yeah we'll be
back
quick 10our stream. Yeah. Thanks for coming on. We'll talk to
you later. Peace. We'll see you. I